the honking is upon us the freedom
convoy has reached ottawa justin trudeau
has fled the city to an undisclosed
location and now vehicles across the
city are slamming their horns honking
like crazy in protest of the vaccine
mandates and of course the people who
live there not every not all of them but
many of them are taking to online forums
outraged saying why won't these people
stop
and the mainstream media in the united
states and canada are smearing the
freedom truckers that's right when the
workers of the world unite the left gets
mad apparently but we've got some
mainstream articles they're calling them
white supremacists who are flinging
feces and stealing from the homeless
wow they are really really and
desperately trying to shut down and lie
about what these truckers are doing
but with ottawa and the honkening comes
the u.s with many u.s truckers and
people just across the country preparing
to engage in their own honking in their
hometown so we got a lot to talk about
there we've got hunter biden's business
associate apparently cooperating on a
tax investigation
maybe something will happen but i'm not
gonna hold my breath and then i just
i gotta bring it up whoopi goldberg
said on the view that the holocaust was
not about race and everybody stared at
her dumbfounded and confused as she
repeatedly doubled down and said it's
just white people doing it to each other
so we're going to have to uh talk about
that one because that is a doozy
joining us
is an individual who has been
disparagingly mentioned in leaked emails
from the clintons peter schweitzer
that's a great intro i told you i was
going to say that
that's great why why why were they uh
disparaging you and
you know i wrote this book called
clinton cash that exposed kind of their
business model i mean they went from
being completely broke
when bill clinton left the white house
to 10 years later they were worth like
250 million dollars
hillary was in the senate she was
secretary of state and they didn't like
the way that i exposed that so um yeah
they had some not such nice things to
say about me i don't think chelsea
always ever disparaged me i never heard
chelsea but bill and hillary were not
happy but now you got a book about uh
biden and xi jinping china yeah it's a
book
about all these americans from the
president congress republicans and
democrats we've got people in silicon
valley bill gates
elon musk and then you look at wall
street the big wall street banks all
doing deals in china and all apologizing
for china and all frankly helping china
in their competition with the united
states so you know i name names and uh
expose them well we will get into all of
that too so thanks for joining us oh
great to be here thanks we've also got
shim cast sheamus coughlin here thank
you for joining us on shim cast irl i am
also besides uh being a podcast host the
creator of freedom tunes so if you want
to go over to freedom tunes check that
out subscribe we do a political cartoon
every single week sometimes twice a week
don't worry yeah and i want to say i'm
very excited for the show because the
pre-show discussion was really fantastic
it was amazing yeah when i'm thinking
about the interactions with china i
think about vladimir lenin's i think his
quote was the capitalists will sell us
the rope that we will use to hang them
or something that's exactly it we'll
sell you the rope you'll use to hang
yourself is that it yourself yeah so
like buying you know chinese goods kind
of makes me think of that metaphor these
days not that we're necessarily at war
but it's a conversation to have yeah and
i am also here pushing buttons in the
corner i'm very excited for this
conversation because like ian was saying
they're definitely selling us the rope
we're gonna hang ourselves with and i'm
afraid we already have so let's see
what's going on with that i kind of feel
like we should get one of those buttons
you can buy where you can record a sound
effect and we should just have like a
honk button like hong kong
because it's like playing through the
show because it's a hunger you know it's
like honk when thing we approve like
james says something good we honk
you would never bonk it everybody those
of you that are listening one like
equals one honk so smash the hunk button
head over to timcast.com become a member
to help support this show and all of our
work each new member is also one hunk so
when you sign up you are also expressing
your distaste for uh trudeau for the
vaccine mandates because you're helping
our journalists write news do their jobs
you're helping us do this show and you
will get access to exclusive members
only segments from this show they go up
monday through thursday at 11 pm we call
them the the uncensored not so
family-friendly version of the show uh
you'll you'll you'll want to check it
out i'll just leave it there because
it's not family friendly and this show
this version is but again go to
timcates.com and don't forget to smash
the like button right now subscribe to
this youtube channel you are currently
on and share the show anywhere you can
because that really does help copying
that url pasting it to facebook twitter
gab getter whatever it is you use
seriously helps we uh we don't have a
marketing budget we just have grassroots
support and uh it is greatly appreciated
but let's get into that first story
justin trudeau says we are not
intimidated trudeau won't meet convoy
that continues to gridlock ottawa
before i read this
i want to give a trigger warning to all
the people who are uh who despise the
mainstream media because
this one my friends this one is a doozy
and i'm not literally giving you a
trigger warning i'm just building
suspense because check this out
they write for the toronto sun
prime minister justin trudeau says he
will neither meet with nor be
intimidated by the convoy of canadians
he says spent the last few days
harassing local businesses waving nazi
flags and stealing food from the
homeless what
are they what is it
all of the smears i have seen of
protests in my day
that
is impressive and i was at occupy wall
street and boy did the media go after
them yeah but this is this is a bunch of
truckers yeah these this is the
lifeblood of any nation delivering goods
angry with vaccine mandates and
protesting it
and that is the characterization used in
the media bravo i'm impressed also can i
ask a question these truckers are
stealing food from the homeless what
about the people who decided that we
needed to print trillions and trillions
of dollars and then inflated our
currency so that lower income people
have less of an ability to buy food are
they stealing food from the homeless
they're stealing from all of us
absolutely what about those people who
on top of that decided we need to impose
a vaccine mandate on the truckers who
literally bring us our food oh yeah i
saw i saw a good post and it said it was
like a lefty thing and said stop saying
labor shortage and start saying living
wage shortage and i responded stop
saying living wage shortage and say
inflation right
right yeah yeah the thing that strikes
me about this it's classic attack the
messenger right so they're going after
the truckers they're making these
ridiculous claims about the truckers
because they don't want to deal with the
substance of the issue and the other
thing i don't understand is he says he's
not going to be intimidated but
didn't justin trudeau like retreat or
leave he's high yeah yeah he's literally
hiding i think he is intimidated by the
truckers isn't he i'm not scared of you
guys i'm not scared at all right he's
like turning around no no he's like i
will not be intimidated breaking news
justin trudeau has fled ottawa to an
undisclosed location exactly so uh let
me let me read this is amazing speaking
to canadians from isolation after
testing positive for coverage oh that's
the reason he played it
he said freedom of expression assembly
and association are cornerstones of
democracy but nazi symbolism racist
imagery and desecration of war memorials
are not it is an insult to memory and
truth hate can never be the answer now
i'm going to tell you this
when blm came to ottawa he came out and
he took a knee with all of them right he
marched with them he protested with them
and i'll also say i i certainly think
anybody involved in that protest should
completely agree yeah nazi symbols
racism and all that stuff not acceptable
we agree thanks justin are you still
scared are you still going to run away
or are you going to come and meet with
the people on the substance yeah the
answer is no well like during the blm
protest did he mention that burning down
people's businesses and destroying their
ability to make a living is horrible and
bad and that he can't set with the
protest on that basis of course not and
then when we're looking at this he's
saying having nazi flags and desecrating
memorials are not something that i'm
willing to contend with okay then how
about we have a conversation about what
they're actually doing okay because if
any of them are even doing that it's a
tiny tiny fringe minority so why doesn't
he talk about the fact that there are
working-class people banding together to
protect their rights as workers
you know this is really interesting
because when i was reading about this
protest it sounds so much like occupy
wall street it sounds like how they went
after occupy and then my response was
hey you know radical left the radical f
did co-opt occupy wall street and turn
it into something else it was a populist
uprising there were libertarians there
were conservatives they were left there
were liberals and they were upset over
the banker bailouts within a couple
weeks though the radical left completely
co-opted the message and the money and
booted out anyone who opposed them so
you know people who are the structure
protest should make sure no ideologue
should be able to take that message yeah
here's the thing i don't get though i
mean it used to be you look back in the
60s you know reagan was governor of
california the anti-war protesters he
didn't agree with him but he'd meet with
them there used to be this tradition you
know if you're a political leader and
somebody's protesting and you don't
agree with them you try to at least meet
i mean justin trudeau is not even
prepared to meet with these guys that's
what's so shocking to me i mean they've
got thousands of people doing this
you've got support for it and justin
trudeau is like no i'm going to pretend
like you don't even exist yeah exactly
well whenever working class people try
to band together to have their voice
heard it's insinuated that there's
something wrong with them as a group of
people for reasons that have nothing to
do with the actual cause they're arguing
for so tim mentioned occupy wall street
and how that was less partisan when it
began interestingly enough the tea party
which was generally to the right was
actually started on msnbc it was a
left-wing pundit who said we need a
modern-day tea party because it is
taxation without representation to spend
money that future generations will have
to pay off right but then of course the
tea party was instantly maligned as a
racist movement right and there were
politicians who claimed i can't remember
who maybe you guys do but that they
called them the n-word and other racial
slurs oh yeah and all of the footage
from the event showed that that did not
happen right right that's the go-to
thing now unfortunately and look i think
we all agree that there are racists out
there and they say racist things and do
racist things but every single time now
there's an event or in a protest this
becomes kind of the shorthand
prescription for what's wrong with the
people or that they're all doing it and
i i just don't buy it i mean i'm sure
that maybe there are a couple of uh
knuckleheads that are doing stupid and
hateful things among the group but the
vast majority and we're just they're
canadian truckers i mean how bad can
they be right they're ordinary
working-class people and this becomes
kind of the go-to explanation for
everything it's it's really
disappointing because when you do
actually have cases of racism that occur
people don't believe it anymore yeah i
also just want to mention it was john
lewis who claimed that he was called
racial slurs by the tea party there was
zero evidence for it and in fact there
was evidence that we're here we heard
the same thing with chuck schumer and
the january 6 protesters
he said they were yelling things about
jews and everyone like just like oh come
on those the writers did a lot of things
but that one is just so over the top
hard to believe yeah show me the footage
this is funny check this out they say
uh he said people were waving hateful
flags including swastikas and the
confederate flag
all right well i did see a photo of
someone with a nazi flag and i'm
genuinely confused by it but like i
guess you know look they're going to be
people and they're going to do dumb
stuff or have believed bad things the
confederate flag is the one that's
really weird to me y'all are in canada i
know what you're doing
so this guy's in saskatchewan right
right
even if someone there was legitimately
like i'm going gonna wave this flag i'd
be like why right well the other thing
too is like these protests happen it
happened in occupy wall street these
truckers show up you know who's to say
the guy with the nazi flag is a trucker
it may have just been some nazi who was
around he was like i'm gonna go in the
crowd and i'm gonna wave my flag around
that's the thing too i i was at a
protest in boston and i was anti-fun one
side the left and the right on the other
side and i was talking to some guy from
the dsa the democratic socialists of
america and uh i asked them what you
know what they were doing with what
their plan was and he was like we just
want you know health care for people and
better policing and i was like what
about you know what would you say to the
critics who would say that you guys are
just communists and that this is a front
and once you get power he was like
that's not true we don't endorse that
stuff
and then i asked him what he thought
about the right
and he was like look you got a bunch of
far right extremists and racists i mean
look they're waving confederate flags
over there and i was like well that's
one guy with a confederate flag he's
like yeah well they're all standing
around him aren't they and i was like
well you guys are waving communist flags
he's like no we aren't and i turned
around like 20 feet away i'm like
there's a gigantic soviet union flag and
they're waving it and he went
well that's not ours
and i was like right right well the
guy's over there it's got one guy with a
confederate flag i mean right you don't
want to throw everybody lump i
understand there's you know different
groups of people here and you know i
don't know if they understand the what
they're saying when they lump everyone
in
but it's it's the same old smear and
this one i gotta admit it's just
outright impressive it's just like the
degree to which the media and the
politicians are are desperate to go
these canadian men were waving
confederate flags it's like well are you
it's you know what it is it's they're
obsessed with american media right so
this is american
you know left sentiment seeping into
canada because i don't i'm look
canadians that are listening explain to
me why someone would wave the
confederate flag i don't get it the
north will rise again
they're north of the north exactly the
north will rise again a yeah
exactly no it's so bizarre also i'm
still uh i'm still getting a kick out of
stealing food from homeless people
that's hysterical who decided like who
printed that is there a story yeah yeah
there's a story that uh some of the
people at the protest went to a homeless
shelter and demanded they give food to
the truckers and the homeless shelter
agreed to to de-escalate things
and then i you know you know i'm willing
to bet i'm willing to bet that it was
like some people walked to the homeless
shelter and said hey would you guys be
willing to give food to the truckers and
they went uh yeah sure thank you and
they're like oh they stole our food they
called the press help us please
something so like it's it's it's it's
mainstream press well you do have to
press i agree with you that it's
probably blown out of proportion but you
do have to be careful with large groups
of people um moving across countries
like that like i think about the um the
crusaders in the crusades man because it
would be all benevolent yay we're
fighting for god we're christian but
they're still human and they need food
so they just pillage on the way they mur
they just take people's food they just
kill they shack up in people's houses
and then
so it can get pretty bad but this is a
different story this is i i trucks it
should be condemned right right no
matter what be alive hey look if that
really happened of course no one's okay
with it there's a story about a guy like
apparently someone threw you know feces
at someone's house because they had a
pride flag and i'm like well that sounds
really absurd to me a monkey but i don't
know
what humans
it sounds really absurd but you know
what i don't care condemn it out right
right nobody's okay with that right and
and if
anybody involved in the in the trucker
protest should be like we're so sorry
someone would know with you guys they
should just outright feel like no one
here agrees with that we're sorry it
happened and with the tens of millions
of dollars raised if it were me that i
do i'd say we're going to clean that up
for you right we're going to cover that
because we want to make sure you know in
fact i would even allocate money to
general street cleaning i'd say we're
going to bring a lot of people you know
we got a lot of trucks coming through we
want to make sure that we can leave the
place where you live clean and tidy up
in fact there was what was that protest
where everyone cleaned up afterwards
recently now i can't remember what it
was we were talking about it a few
months ago like a bunch of right-wing
people came and they protested i know
what you're talking about they all
cleaned up the garbage
though yeah yeah yeah and when you when
you look at these left-wing rallies at
the women's march it's just totally
trashed right disgusting just
obliterated yeah yeah well here we are
so where does this end tim i mean you
know you've got these guys protesting
where does this end people are still we
have some super chats you know we save
them for the end but people are
mentioning that the convoy is not even
in the city yet oh really like it's been
a it was 50 miles long
and so you have 50 000 truckers so what
we're seeing is just the tip
just the tip i'm entering yeah well i
just want to say i'm so proud of canada
and canadians here my whole life i had
this perception that they were much more
complacent and i think that's the image
of them that sold to us especially
because their government is so much more
restrictive than ours but not long ago i
started to actually speak to people from
canada and i found that many of them are
really quite
convicted and and based and actually
understand what's going on and want to
resist uh tyranny and so i love that
they're sending this message to the
world amen i don't know for sure if the
canadian most canadians would be like yo
let's let's join the americans instead
of the british like if they had to pick
but i imagine they'd be like yeah all
right yeah what do you mean you mean
during the revolutionary no like today
if you got to side with democratic
freedom democratic republicanism or have
you got a side with the monarchy you
side with democratic republicanism yeah
yeah uh uh quebec was the 14th the 14th
colony though you know they said no they
were like we will not declare
independence yeah it's an interesting
point you may because i was just reading
a book on
the american revolution war for
independence and you know i always kind
of thought like everybody was on board
with kicking the british out and the
best estimate was like one-third of them
yeah wanted independence one-third of
them were loyal and the other third were
kind of in between and you kind of
wonder is that the way it always is you
know these big changes that you have
what's what's going on in canada right
now is it kind of the rule of thirds
right that that it's not an overwhelming
majority of people and you got to
persuade that other third so the things
you were talking about about cleaning up
the streets about condemning things
that's a way to win that other third and
get the majority but i kind of feel like
we're almost to the point where there is
no other third you know we looked at a
lot of polling we've looked at a lot of
polling over the past several months the
independent base is is melting yeah as
people keep switching so there's people
switching from at least in the u.s
democrat to republican independents are
being pulled left and right with the
biggest group of independents going
republican the republican party is
starting to balance out and gain on the
on the democratic party but there's
almost no middle anymore if you're if
you're a centrist i mean like i feel
like this show we do is a balance of
opinion it's called right wing by the
left right and it's it's the most insane
thing because i mean i i watch some
conservative shows and i'm like i can
certainly see the difference between the
show we do in the show they do and so
can our viewers but if you're on the
left it's all right-wing right so when
you get to that point it's almost like
do you really win that third or i mean i
guess so obviously we're trying to we're
trying to convince those people to join
freedom and i think it's working because
even democrat voters are switching over
to republican not that republican is the
right answer mind you it's just like
people feel like it's their only
alternative right but things are hyper
polarizing right but there are there are
a group of people who are kind of
apolitical right i mean they have
cultural opinions they but
a political and i agree with you it's a
diminishing group to what it used to be
um but i just want to believe and hope
that there is a persuadable group in the
country and that that you can and that's
why you need to do these things and
demonstrate
you know how important uh your views and
values are and and do things like you
were saying clean up the streets and
i think every everyone is persuadable to
a certain degree and i think it's not
about a middle ground a one-third i
think we're actually looking at democrat
voter base we're looking at
default liberal types i think that's
what andrew breitbart called them right
default liberals so they're they vote
democrat they align the democratic party
they say that they're democrats and now
they're watching what's going on and
they're rolling their eyes and saying yo
i'm out many of them are voting for
republican many i think pew referred to
them as the stressed sideline
but i don't think you know uh
it's large enough at this point i think
what's actually happening is
shows like this shows like joe rogan and
other you know other shows even
conservative ones and even some left
ones like jimmy dore are eroding at the
establishment narrative and it's
resulting in people just saying i'm done
with that group of people the celebrity
message i mean look at that story waving
nazi flags and hate symbols like
seriously right there was a tweet from
kurt schlichter is really funny i can't
remember exactly what he said but he was
like the left is really mad when that
the workers of the world are uniting
it's like it's kind of funny how that's
working out right these are truckers
these are uh like you know typically
young younger to middle-aged guys who
are just driving on the road and you
know people of all different backgrounds
honestly who drive trucks but uh
not the kind of people you expect to be
marching around throwing bricks through
windows right right and here we are with
the smears and the manipulation and no i
mean yeah well these are people with a
sense of responsibility they have jobs
that's the entire reason that they're
protesting it's for their rights as
workers these are not irresponsible
teenagers who are going out trying to
destroy things like we saw for an entire
summer that was never condemned by any
of the people who are condemning all of
these truckers for something that a
fringe minority within their group is
doing and who quite frankly we don't
even know is a fringe minority within
their group they could just these could
just be randos showing up yeah yeah yeah
so you you asked like where does this
all go
you know what's fascinating that this
story is happening in canada
and uh you know i was talking with you
know people just before the show and i
think that's my brother who said it's
like a global civil war almost because
it's not just the united states that's
experiencing this cultural rift it's
it's europe canada the united states
australia australia and to a certain
extent australia and new zealand but
australia man
things are bad there what is it that the
british empire's crumbling is that
basically finally yeah maybe like 600
years or something it's it's it's the
culture that was born out of uh mostly i
guess british colonization they it's due
to physics they figured out physics
first isaac newton so then they had
long-range cannon fire from boats and
they dominated the city
and uh and steam gatling guns i was
reading about allowed them to just
dominate but uh it's interesting it's
it's not just the former british
colonies
and and you know kind the commonwealth
there's parts of europe too but it
really does feel like people say western
civilization and all stuff and i'm like
it is very much like canada the us
australia new zealand uh britain the
five eyes spy club whatever you want to
call it certain parts of europe but you
look to some of these european countries
and they're like either getting rid of
their vaccine their covet mandates
completely right and just go back to
normal and then you look at the united
states you look at canada you look to
you you look at the uk and this the same
culture war thing is happening across
the board
so why why is that i don't know but
when i talk about you know the potential
for civil war and stuff like that i do
find it fascinating that now the
establishment left is completely on
board with the narrative you know you've
got this one guy put out a book recently
the next civil war you've got msnbc
talking about the new york times the
wall street journal the atlantic they're
all now saying like where are we headed
and then if you actually you when we
look at what's going on with the
truckers we look at how trudeau responds
when they start claiming that working
class people in trucks are like evil
white supremacist nazis and all that
stuff i'm like
there there is no convincing this other
side you either concede to them give
them concession or you assert yourself
now and recognize the groups are two
completely separate groups that will not
ever work together there's no convincing
them because claus schwab and i don't
want to put it on you klaus there's
probably other people involved they
don't want to
not think this it's inten they're
intentionally choosing to believe that
there's some sort of rift so it's like
you can't convince someone that is going
to
choose to believe it
does that make sense yeah yeah
i see i see luke's in the comments
trying to help
no we don't read his comments now he
left us yeah he did so we'll just ignore
luke's comments no no luke said it was
uh it's called the great reset it's part
of the great reason yeah maybe but but
uh
it's you know adrian curry commented too
that it's china you know that's that's
selling this this uh dissent i wonder
what your thought is uh peter on you
know this this this culture what's
happening in canada the us and the uk
some have suggested we've had guests on
the show that say
you know china's got troll armies that
sew dissent they push these messages and
they're very divisive so i'm wondering
what your thoughts are yeah i think it
is a factor i think the the you know
it's simplifying it somewhat but i think
the fundamental debate is
you know where do our rights come from
and people on the left say that our
rights come from government government
tells us what our rights are and if
you're somebody i don't even want to say
necessarily conservative right wing i
think it's just a way of viewing it the
other alternative view is that no our
rights come from god or come from the
fact that we are human beings and that
we are sovereign and it seems to me
that's what so many of these debates are
about and uh china i think is playing a
big role they have these troll armies
that try to
pick fights and so division online one
of the things i talk about in the book
are um these very wealthy uh chinese
oligarchs look red-handed yeah the book
red-handed exactly um
a lot of these oligarchs that made their
money with these state-owned companies
or these state-linked companies like
alibaba and whatnot um there's a guy
featured in the book named josiah he
lives in california he's worth 20
billion dollars very tight with the ccp
government
and he goes on college campuses saying
there are no human rights problems in
china everything's great but at the same
time he's given a hundred million
dollars to black lives matter causes and
he talks about how unjust america is and
how
you know does he have right to do that
sure but how can you in any universe
argue that america is this horribly
unjust bigoted society and say that
communist china is a great place to live
it's it's uh uh it's interesting china
versus america is very much the same
culture war as
internally in america right yeah so i'll
give you an example of what i'll break
down what i mean the left is willing to
uh
the establishment left and many left as
a cultural leftist lie cheat and steal
to say whatever they have to say in
order to win
they'll ban censor shut down silence etc
the right is constantly trying to play
by some kind of rules and i don't mean
like the establishment right i mean the
culture war right which includes
libertarians moderates post liberals et
cetera they're constantly saying thing
that you know it's remarkable just to
i'm not going to get into the overt
specifics but it's obvious to anybody
who watches the right is constantly
trying to have a conversation with the
left that the left is uninterested in
having right the left has asserted its
position as true and unfalsifiable and
so be it therefore but the right keeps
saying you know let's let's let's work
out a deal simple example is like you
know joe rogan in spotify they want to
ban joe rogan they want to shut his show
down so they start pulling their music
off the platform in response joe and
spotify give some concessions okay we'll
put we'll put advisories on these
podcasts but what about podcasts with
fouchy are they going to include dr
robert malone in those advisors they're
not going to do it so what keeps
happening is
the freedom-loving individuals keep
conceding some points to the
authoritarian left now on the grand
international scale it's the same thing
with china china is absolutist the
communist party you oppose us you get
crushed who's that guy jack ma was that
his name yeah gone money wiped away
because how dare you right but
in the united states we don't do that to
a certain degree you'll get canceled if
you cross the line and you'll lose you
know because it's once against the
authoritarian left but because of this
power imbalance and uh
i would call it integrity and principle
imbalance china can look at someone like
lebron james and say yeah we're going to
give you 10 million dollars never talk
bad about us he goes you got it yeah
then he comes to the united states where
the left plays by a similar game and
they say
don't screw with us we are the ones who
are going to make sure your contracts
stay in but if you challenge us we'll
get them revoked so what happens america
is really bad why the left agrees and
the chinese communist party agrees right
those that are playing by the rules are
getting wiped out yeah and then
bizarrely there's a consistency to that
that the united states is terrible in
china is great and in both cases you get
paid you don't pay any price really in
today's culture popular culture
uh for you know disagreeing with blm i
mean you get cancelled so the the path
to least resistance is basically to
embrace these sort of left-wing ideas
and it's the same thing with china and
you never pay a price for it i mean as i
point out in the book with lebron james
everybody knows the recent thing about
the the tweeting about hong kong and how
he was defending them
it goes back i mean he's been doing this
for like 15 years there was a
crisis you guys might remember back in
uh 2007 2008 darfur
you you had in sudan you know 200 000
black christians were slaughtered in the
south by this regime the regime was
backed by the chinese government and
there was actually a petition in the nba
to call out china because they were
backing this regime that was
slaughtering black christians and lebron
james refused to sign the petition
so for a guy who says black lives matter
yeah the for a guy who believes black
lives matter as we all do
those black lives did not matter to him
because he did not want to offend china
but but come on peter just just i want
you to imagine something all right yeah
it's a snowy beautiful mountain
you're up top in a big 8 000 square foot
cabin
one the whole north face of the building
is one big glass window and you wake up
and you press the coffee button on your
keurig and it makes you a nice hot
cappuccino and you know you walk to the
window and you look at this beautiful
sunset you smile to yourself and say
this 40 million cabin was worth selling
out all of those suffering people and
you sip it and that's what i imagine is
going through lebron and all these other
guys's heads when they're when they're
they buy these properties and the money
is is that they they genuinely believe
it's worth it well and it's interesting
that the people who are able to afford
to buy off famous celebrities to espouse
their political views are almost all on
the left and one question i want to pose
to everybody is
when justin trudeau talks about these
truckers do you think he actually knows
any do you think justin trudeau has
anyone in his life who does that
professionally
and i see it as a problem
not necessarily of income inequality but
of economic stratification so in the
past income inequality existed but you
were hanging out with people who were in
different income brackets you knew
farmers you knew plumbers you knew
people who were in the working class
even if you had an accounting job and a
lot of that was the community that was
built up at your church and i can
testify to that as well
at my church in my social group we're
fortunate enough to have all sorts of
people from different economic brackets
because we're focused on a larger
mission
but nowadays people really gravitate
towards their own in-group with respect
to wealth and then they sort of pat
themselves in the back because they
think their particular in-group because
it's left-leaning represents the views
of the working class but then when they
hear what actual working-class people
have to say they lose their minds so i
think at the end of the day a question
that you need to ask yourself about any
political leader is is this a person who
would fit in better with like walmart
shoppers or whole foods shoppers
and justin trudeau is not gonna fit in
with a group of people who live normal
lives he's not a whole foods shopper
he's uh what's that place called arowan
is that what it's called never been
there but it's is it called erawan i
don't know i've never heard that name
maybe
i don't know no there's there's a really
really really expensive uh grocery store
in l.a that all the celebrities go to
maybe i got the name totally wrong yeah
we look it up but it's like i was
thinking but that's not really no no
i was outside once and i saw jake
gyllenhaal like walk in
and it's like that's where the
celebrities shop that's just you know
what's funny is um
yeah i think you make it really great i
know what you're talking about i mean is
it
arrow arrows announced e-r-e-w-h-o-n
yeah yeah you looked it up yeah i did
okay there you go there you go
just justin trudeau is the kind of guy
who like walks into a grocery store and
there's no milk and he's like there must
be a mistake where's the milk and then
they're like well the truckers have
stopped driving he's like what does that
do with the milk
well mr trudeau the truckers bring the
milk they do what and i i honestly think
that when it comes to people like
trudeau or when it comes to so many of
these woke left-wing people first of all
having those views is almost certainly
an indicator that you spend most of your
time with really wealthy people yeah and
secondarily
if you do hold those views generally
when you're dealing with a working class
person it's because you're telling them
what to do and they have to because it's
their job and so i think that's a big
part of the reason why they're
completely unwilling to negotiate
because from their perspective they
always get to tell people in this
bracket what to do and they obey so when
they stand up for themselves they can't
stand it it's not just that they can't
stand it they can't even comprehend it
it has to be racism they have to put it
in this box of some sort of bigotry
because that's the only way they know
how to analyze the world is um is
trudeau um a servant of the canadian
people like in the united states or is
he a puppet of the queen he's a question
he's supposed to be a servant but you
know it's it's it's interesting at the
heart of what you're saying and what
what you shameless were saying earlier
um there's a quote in the book i have
because the trudeau family has this long
history of relationship with the chinese
government and there's this uh amazing
question that justin trudeau's asked in
2012 he's a member of parliament and
he's asked is there anybody on the world
stage that you as a political figure
sort of really admire you know some
country in the world
and he doesn't say the united states he
doesn't say great britain he says china
he says i admire china and they ask why
do you admire china and his answer to
your point shameless is well you know if
you're the leader of china you can just
get [ __ ] done you can get things done
you know it's efficient and he talks
about climate change and he says you
know you don't have to debate all these
things you just get things done you know
how you respond to someone like that
like if i was sitting down if i was
talking to trudeau and he said that i'd
be like you know justin
spot on i mean when you've got a global
pandemic for instance and you can just
weld the doors shut poor people exactly
so they just die
you don't gotta worry about a pandemic
why should i get sick let them die you
know what i mean right and it's like
it's like you know i you know look i'm
trying to build a highway for instance
and these poor people think they can own
land just get them out allow them out of
the way yeah where do they live who
cares screw them they're poor people
they're not paying taxes right right now
if there's a certain efficiency to a
dictatorship and that's attractive to
justin trudeau and there's other people
that say the same thing but trudeau it's
so interesting to me because it's
exactly what you guys were saying
earlier that that he doesn't have a
connection
people become
just these objects you move around on
the chessboard right if you don't have a
connection with them if you don't if you
don't know truckers if you don't know
farmers you just they're they're things
to be moved around on a chessboard and
that's the mentality of a dictator
exactly and i i apologize if i was a
little snide you in my reply to you sort
of asking if if trudeau was a servant
but
i also think that it's so telling that
when trudeau
is looking at communist china the person
he empathizes with is the dictator the
person in control like he doesn't look
at communist china right and think about
the people living there and how horrible
that would be he immediately associates
himself with the communist dictator
that's very telling how how that doesn't
end a political career i will never know
i like how people call justin trudeau
castro yeah
like castro
well because they they ea you they're
strong i mean there are people who
genuinely believe he's the son of fidel
castro right but just in terms of being
a dictator just castro is is is so uh on
point he was born to pierre right pierre
yeah
so he was basically raised
bred to be elite a leader i don't like
that that's not the right word yeah
brett to be a prime minister right uh
obviously
well i i think he might be a poor leader
um i agree so what so he was just
raised psychotically in that environment
yeah i mean it it's it's funny when you
look at the the family history like his
dad pierre trudeau he was the one that
opened up relations between canada and
and china
diplomatic relations and then when he
left the prime ministership and he had
been like this pro kind of mao he wrote
this like ridiculous book where he went
to china and he you know meets these uh
you know pioneer children you know like
these seven-year-old kids running around
with the red flags and they're chanting
these maoist sayings and he's saying
this is the future of the country but
when he leaves the the premiership in
canada he opens up a consultancy uh
helping getting businesses juiced in
with the communist leadership in china
because he had a good relationship with
him so that's where the trudeau family
money comes from
and so justin grew up very privileged
courtesy of the fact that his dad was
doing all these deals in mainland china
i had no idea that's where the family
wealth comes from yeah that's really
found from wow from a series of uh of
deals that he did and justin's got a
younger brother who's kind of a form
policy adviser of his name's alexander
has written some like insanely horrific
things about china
again kind of this admiration for
dictatorship people don't understand it
he says like you know canadians in a way
are less free than people in china
it's it's ridiculous stuff and and
that's sort of the background of what
justin trudeau grew up in what he heard
from his dad what he heard from his
brother and it now influences the way
that he deals with china so when he sees
truckers
uh in canada you know it's not hard to
take a leap and say this is the you know
imagine how a chinese leader would look
at you know truckers in china if they
were doing the same thing he goes you
know i really wish i could just take
their organs that would be such it would
be a far more efficient country that'd
be a way better way of doing things
thank you justin do you think that china
is we've asked a lot of people this is
actively engaged in sowing the conflict
in our countries yes making the culture
worse absolutely um you know and you
look at look at various things you look
at the donations that some of these guys
are that are connected to the regime are
making they're making donations to these
divisive groups
you look at i think the whole question
of covid i mean i'm not an expert but
you at least got to entertain the idea
uh that that it was a lab leak but you
know in congress there hasn't been a
single congressional hearing about the
origins of covid and i'm convinced part
of it is because nancy pelosi and her
family have their deals with canada
there have been hearings that have
addressed it yeah but
yeah rand paul has raised the question
but they they you know to have a
congressional hearing that says we're
going to explore the origins of covid
and and lab leak nancy pelosi has
refused to allow any of them being held
on the house side the other thing i
would add is is is on china is look at
the whole fentanyl you know issue
absolutely i mean where does the
fentanyl come from and it's not just
fentanyl it's designer drugs as well
yeah you familiar so for those for those
that aren't familiar designer drugs
typically are some kind of narcotic or
drug that is slightly altered in such a
way that it now is legal although good
luck explained to the cop the molecules
that i have here are slightly different
but a lot of this stuff comes from china
they are they are producing drugs and
shipping them over here illegally and
they're they're killing people yeah i
mean it's it's it's fourth and fifth
generational war it is it is indirect
but it is massively damaging the the
fentanyl problem and then potentially
the the drugs that come here designer
drugs or otherwise could be laced with
something and cause even more problems
yes this is the reversal of the uh opium
wars it is the opium wars we're still in
them yeah it's revenge it's 100 years
later 120 years later we're still in the
opium wars now they're just feeding it
back to us through mexico yeah so well
so explain that what does that what does
that mean well you know the opium wars
um uh because of the opium trade and in
in asia the british empire and other
powers sort of divided up they were so
hungry to get access to opium and export
it that um they took over portions
portions of china and china became not
completely but kind of a vassal state
and they had a huge drug problem in
china as well because of this demand
and then they finally gained enough sort
of national sovereignty to sort of beat
it away but you actually find literature
of
you know chinese military officers and
others saying
when fentanyl comes up well
this is revenge for the opium war was
that was that related to the boxer
rebellion
that was a part of it yeah that was part
of it but but you know china has been uh
obsessed and i understand because this
is terrible part of their history
with extracting revenge on the western
powers because they were so weakened
they were this empire uh that had been
largely defeated by the west uh and they
want revenge and you see g talks about
this all the time talks about this all
the time that that you know by 2049
they're going to be seized the
commanding heights on the global stage
they're going to you know overcome the
united states and there there's going to
be payback for what the western powers
did to his country 150 years earlier so
what the then is klaus how does klaus
schwab into this is he like
accelerating this communist insurgence
into the united states you know it's so
funny on all these guys you look at um
uh you know some like elon musk and
these guys have elon musk says some
great things and he says some crazy
things about china about how china is
more representative than the united
states and i mean it's just crazy stuff
and you have to decide with all these
guys whether it's klaus schwab is are
they just doing it for the money
um or do some of them actually believe
it um and i think some of them actually
believe it i think a lot of them do it
because they want access to china they
want access to the chinese market uh a
guy like klaus schwab i think is a true
believer and he said you know that that
hey they've got good market reforms in
china and yeah you know it's you got
this dictatorship but that's less
important because they've got this
market that they've set up it's it's
it's crazy stuff so he's i think a true
believer he's not just doing it is it
because the
i i don't the chinese bank does it get
its money from the bank of international
settlements in switzerland as well as so
could klaus and his buddies just shut
off the chinese economy so they're
really not afraid of the chinese
government it'd be hard to shut off the
chinese economy because it's so wedded
in so many ways financially and
otherwise and that's been the thing
right we were told for 30 years
for 30 years if we just traded with them
if we just gave them you know access to
our financial markets if we let them
watch our movies and you know buy our
clothes they're going to become more
like us
and no they haven't they're they're a
dictator we've become more like them
amen elon musk is tweeting support for
the truckers yes and there's there's
rumors going on i haven't i haven't
verified this but liar.com is reportedly
owned by elon musk i don't know if
that's true but people are claiming it
is and it links to trudeau's wikipedia
page and it's associated with a 42 000
donation i don't know if any that's true
so fact check that one but it's a viral
tweet going around where people are
claiming this yeah and maybe elon musk
is just playing uh both sides yeah it
could be and look i i think in musk's
case if i were to guess you know he's
got a big tesla factory in china they
built it for him china's a big growth
market
he's saying stuff because he wants
access to the market but some of these
wall street guys they they are true
believers they they believe in these
leaders they think they're better than
ours they think the system is better
than ours um and and to my mind they're
just sellouts well can i ask you how
could they possibly believe something
like that are they genocide deniers do
they pretend that it's not actually
happening over there or do they think
that their market is so efficient that
it justifies that kind of behavior well
so i'll give you an example that sort of
blows my mind there's a guy i don't know
if you guys have heard of his name's ray
dalio he runs the largest hedge fund in
the united states bridgewater associates
and he wrote a book in 2017 called
principles which is ironic based on what
i'm about to tell you in that book he
talks about
a the second most powerful man in china
named wonky sean who he says i've known
him for a long time and he says wonky
sean has almost helped me tap the
secrets of the universe and he talks
about this quasi-religious experience
that he's had just meeting with these
guys this guy he's so wise i've learned
so much from him and he's been this
remarkable force for good for like 30
years i thought well who the hell is
this wonky shanghai so i started looking
it up
he's g's enforcer he's in charge of
party discipline he's the guy that
throws people in jail and has them
tortured now why would you as a smart
guy like ray dalio
write something like that
and then you realize that he wrote that
he said a bunch of other nice things and
then his hedge fund got the first
opportunity of any other hedge fund in
the world to sell hedge fund products to
the chinese
i guess
if you're if you're elite if you're
extremely wealthy you feel safe and
secure in doing your dealings yes and
then it's the people of the world who
suffer for it yes yeah if you're elite i
mean you're assuming if things go south
you're still going to be okay your
family's going to be saying i think
you're right yeah and you know not to
make any specific uh accusations about
ray dalio here right but we do know
statistically that people who trade on
wall street are actually more likely to
be psychopaths and sociopaths now i
can't give someone that that kind of
diagnosis but those are the behaviors of
a psychopath to praise somebody who
would do that kind of thing because you
think it'll get you money we have we
have this big story that i want to get
into and uh it's we find ourselves once
again talking about joe rogan and
spotify but this is a good example of
the of the cultural imbalance so the
quick story is that spotify is
announcing an addition of content
warnings
over the criticism of joe rogan and
covet 19 misinformation but we never get
this the other direction when rachel
maddow or fauci or cnn puts out bunk
garbage twitter doesn't flag them you
put out something that goes against
fauci or mata or cnn twitter flags you
so joe rogan has on sanjay gupta mike
osterholm experts establishment voices
nobody cares right he has on mikola and
um and malone and it's the apocalypse
joni mitchell these old aging hippies
are like i want censorship and then you
know niels lofgren now to be fair they
both both neil young and and lofgren
said we don't want to censor joe rogan
we just want off the platform because we
don't want to share it with them okay
that's actually respectable because you
know if i that's the right thing to do
if i was on a platform and i was like i
don't like that they support hate speech
right i'll leave yeah so good bye bye
that's good yeah but we can see what
happens from the backlash you're never
going to get a concession from the
establishment to recognize independent
voice it's always the other way around
so long as this imbalance exists we are
all being pulled hard towards the
authoritarian side of things and that
being said
a story like this i think just shows
they have no effective means of stopping
joe rogan real conversations
conversations like this so despite this
being kind of bad here's the big update
spotify shares recover after joe rogan
addressed the vaccine controversy as
taylor swift fans calling her to pull
her music from the streaming service
it's not gonna happen spotify may suck
on pay rates and all that but the moment
they come out and say oh okay we'll do
this little content warning which
ultimately i think will do nothing right
it may be a net negative in certain
capacity the spotify shares rebound and
i think you know joe and everyone else
is going to pull out of this and they're
going to walk away from this unscathed
yeah i think the thing that that helps
joe rogan here is he's such an important
part of the company because he's got
such a massive audience the interesting
question and i don't know the answer to
it is
spotify has a number of large chinese
investors that own portions of that does
that play into this censorship i don't
know we know with twitter you know jack
dorsey hired senior executives because
he wanted to break into china that had
ties with the communist party um this
censorship issue we talked earlier about
it i think we are becoming more like
china china's not becoming more like us
we'll be coming we're importing some of
these censorship tools that they use
well uh what do you think about
blackrock
uh blackrock uh is terrible uh they're
the focus in my book think about this
for a second real quick sorry just uh
yeah can you explain what blackrock is
yeah blackrock is the largest financial
asset manager in the world
and and what does that mean
they manage 10 trillion dollars that's
with a t
the gross national product of the united
states is like 21 trillion so they
manage almost like 50
of the united states gross national
product financially so they are the 900
pound gorilla of world finance i want to
show something real quick before we get
into that in reference this is something
i've shown on the show before but we'll
show again in this context there's
something i posted and i want to just
issue the the disclaimer before going
through this
blackrock owns basically everything
right so i'm not trying to post these
things to make an assertion of some
grand conspiracy but i think it's
important to show the business
connections yeah so this is neil young
sells catalog rights to mercur
mercuria
mercuritis is hypnosis
blackstone and hypnosis song management
launch a billion-dollar partnership
blackstone announced his appointment of
jeffrey b kindler former chairman and
ceo of pfizer as a senior advisor
spotify to paul neil young's music
objecting to joe rogan so uh not that i
think it's necessarily evidence that
someone at blackstone you know put to
the phone and said we need to pull a
neil young on this one and get him but
it shows that it very well may have been
a meeting where they're just like look
this joe rogan's show is bad for us it
hurts our profits and shares what are
our assets like well we do have this
music catalog that does work with
spotify all right get them on the phone
and see if there's anything there it's
possible it's entirely possible
blackstone it's got its pinky and
everything and it's got it's got mean
it's got uh interests and a conflict of
interest and all of this stuff yeah i
mean blackrock is massive and huge and
uh they
are very interested and supportive of
this kind of authoritarian model so
think about this for a second in 2017
the communist party of china goes to
hong kong you know they have the hong
kong stock exchange all these companies
on it goes to the hong kong stock
exchanges every company listed here um
has to uh put in its company charter
that the communist party of china gets
the final decision in every corporate
decision
now this had to be voted on by the
shareholders in these companies right in
hong kong so vanguard you know big
financial company votes against it
absolutely we do not want this wow
blackrock
voted in favor
but isn't vanguard bad as well yeah i'm
sure they're bad but i'm saying on this
in contrast i mean at least some of them
got right blackrock actually said no we
actually think this is a good idea
what's the what's the gdp of china uh
the gdp of china is is uh you know
probably about 60 percent of the united
states so
blackrock might be like we can take them
we're getting there yeah not for real
yeah i mean but china's growing fast
yeah it is growing fast seven eight
percent clip and they're expected to
surpass us in a few years so i wonder if
you know we look at stuff like joe
rogan's show and
the fact that he's just some regular guy
kind of comedian populist being so so
successful we i look at a lot of this
and i'm like clearly the free speech is
winning but in the long run china's
growth outweighs ours will it matter if
we have cultural victories when the
economic victory is in china's lap
uh it's a good question and i think it
depends on on what we think the the
average american is going to do i still
think the average american is the center
of gravity ultimately if if the average
american rises up and says we're not
going to tolerate this they can still
win over elites
and i want to believe that there's still
the fight there right that
the average american when they see these
things being eroded they get pushed far
enough they're going to stand up and say
push no more we're done yeah but i think
what we saw with the uh with the coveted
lockdowns a good portion of this country
are just like yeah tell me what to do
and i'll do it yeah although they didn't
you know they didn't lock down in
certain states because i knew they
couldn't get away with it but you're
right california new york a lot of
places a lot of people kind of cave
right yeah but like we knew we couldn't
count on them anyway
no no the californians and the new
yorkers were no help well that's that's
the scary uh future projection it's
really funny there was a
i got a facebook reminder and it was
like old memories and it was a post i
made in 2017 where i was like
authoritarian dictatorship is coming to
the united states it was early 2017 i
said the conspiracy theory is trump
being the trojan horse for
authoritarianism because he will be
demonized and vilified to the point
where it rallies the left into accepting
authoritarianism and then in the name of
stopping the rise of fascism you get
hardcore far left pro china right and
then you know that it was kind of just
like something i'd see on the internet
and i typed up
but uh there's there's other theories
other other you know i shouldn't say
theories but like
people genuinely believe if it came to
like donald trump winning in 2024 that
people in california would clap and
cheer when china landed you know u-boats
or something on the shores to come in
and save them from fascism or something
like that yeah i mean you look at
history when when dictators have taken
over they never come and say hey i'm
going to be your dictator i'm going to
control your life it's always i'm going
to protect you from this terrible evil
thing that's even worse than me well so
i don't know if you saw the boston globe
story from uh 2020 election where they
said you know it was like podesta and
donna brazile were war gaming as the
democrats and they had pressured the
west west coast states to secede from
the union should donald trump win
now if that kind of sentiment actually
did exist what do you think let's let's
imagine there is some kind of national
divorce or whatever right and then come
2024 donald trump is like you know got
his hand on the bible and he's like i am
the new 47th president or whatever and
then california oregon washington
they're like yo we out yeah what what
happens i mean does china just see an
opportunity do they just say oh it's
fair game because who's got hawaii now
that the western states are cut off from
the rest of the country
who's going to defend taiwan i mean
actually i kind of think taiwan would
fall before then if that were the case
yeah yeah no i think i think um china of
course would love a divided america and
they're pushing for it in so many
different ways and unfortunately there
are
a substantial number of americans i
would say mostly on the political left
although there's probably some on the
right that that actually fear
their fellow americans more than they
fear a regime in china or these other
cases and that that that's just tragic
that's just tragic and
yeah i mean i mean look at the defense
that uh the establishment waged for
china when trump was engaging in the
trade war exactly it was like oh this is
wrong and bad you shouldn't do this it's
going to destabilize the global economy
it's bad for everybody and it's like yo
they have concentration camps like we're
talking about yeah yeah and the chinese
leaders said uh you know that their best
lobbyists were wall street they didn't
have to lobby they didn't have to lobby
i mean they outright said it we don't
have to lobby the trump administration
on tariffs because wall street will do
us for us wow yep unbelievable so where
does that line do you think are are you
familiar with thucydides strap
yes do you think we for those aren't
familiar it's a you know a rising
economic power reaching the dominant
power it typically results in war do you
think we're heading that direction uh i
i think so in a way but i also think
there's a very real opportunity i think
china is a
brittle regime i don't think it has the
widespread support that people think it
does i think it's very akin to the
soviet union you have this cast of
people on the top that benefit from the
system but you've got a lot of people
that are resentful of it in china you
have the economic growth you didn't have
in the soviet union but you have a huge
problem in the fact that you know china
had this one child policy for so long
and so what ended up happening was um
you know parents wanted to have one
child they wanted to be a boy they
didn't want to be a girl because a boy
is going to provide for them in their
old age so the estimates are that in
some cases you know within a demographic
group of like 25 to a 40 year olds there
may be like 150 million more men in
china than there are women now that that
is grounds for a civil war in that
country yes no no joke i mean look you
wanna you wanna get serious for a minute
and also people are gonna laugh and
probably roll their eyes especially the
feminists but
150 million more men you said yes so
those are going to be guys who can't get
women can get dates in cells seriously
and they're gonna they're gonna lose it
right i mean it's not it's not about
making fun of neckbeard it's not about
making fun it's about young men who have
literally no opportunity to f to fulfill
a a a massive internal desire for having
a family right and they are going to
have nothing yeah they're going to lose
their minds well when you look at the
vast majority of the crime problem in
this country including really heinous
insane crimes that rarely occur such as
massacres or school shootings or whether
it's just street crime like a burglary
they're almost all committed by men who
feel as if they have no buy-in to the
system and they have no way to rise up
and be successful and a huge part of
that is the ability to start a family
right and if you don't believe that
there's any hope for that you're going
to become a deranged individual if you
don't have that hope it's so necessary
and it's such an important part of being
a man and a productive person in general
and so if china has 150 million men who
have no prospect of ever being with a
woman
that is going to be unbelievably and
horrifically damaging to that country
except
colonization yeah so we are seeing the
modern form of colonization from china
as many people who live there to escape
crowding and find better you know better
better lives
are leaving the country so a lot of
these young men might just say i've got
to leave china and go somewhere else to
try and find a life and i just want to
make this clear what i'm talking when
i'm talking about men who have no buying
to the system i'm not i'm not talking
about like oh they're not accountable
for their actions or something like that
but the link i'm trying to draw is
usually when we talk about someone like
a school shooter for example we'll we'll
highlight the fact that this was an
incel
right and like these are it's really
it's not exactly the perfect term for it
but it's like you have 150 million in
cells you could get them vr porn and but
i don't know if sticking people in a
machine with digital pornography is
enough to make them not psychotically i
mean it's another kind of psychosis and
i got to say that's absurd obviously you
get them waifu body pillows yeah right
yeah well i'm talking about after i was
i thought that that one already hadn't
worked out that would work so we had to
i wonder if china's gonna stick a bunch
of people in pods try and generate their
piezoelectric heat for electricity and a
little hope they don't go crazy i'm with
you to a certain degree in like uh vr
girlfriends and stuff like that to try
and uh you know or like robots or
something to try and you know
calm the rage
but uh i don't know about harness you
know pulling a matrix on them in that
capacity maybe maybe a little too
premature
i think um leaving the country is a more
i think
i think we're gonna see
waves of you know uh adult chinese men
just moving out and trying to find wives
in other places so now we if we can
think 20 years in the future what would
we do now to present an environment for
those people to come because we need to
make way for these displaced chinese men
yeah i don't know yeah i mean it's it's
it's a good question i mean it it to me
it's one example of the fact that china
has problems too it's not like they're
this super power that can't be
uh you know uh defeated that that
they're inevitably gonna be more
powerful than us
so i think we need to recognize that and
we need to play to our strengths not
play to their strengths and i think you
know when you look at china the problem
is the chinese communist party it's not
the chinese people um you know reagan
said that in the cold war our enemies
are not the russians it's this it's the
soviet leadership and i view the same
way with china we've gotta have that
reagan sorry uh trump did some of that
in his speaking um his secretary of
state did the same thing joe biden lumps
it all together china is china it's not
you got a clique that's running the
country uh that is oppressing the rest
of them and then you've got the ordinary
chinese who you know cannot be that
happy with the chinese communist party
well let's talk about what's going on at
home for a minute see if we can clean up
the mess down here we got the story from
the new york post hunter biden's former
business partners cooperated completely
with feds in tax probe the new york post
reports devin archer who was awaiting
sentencing in an unrelated fraud case is
among four people reportedly referenced
in a may 15-19 subpoena first reported
by the post sent to jp morgan to chase
bank for records related to any
transaction involving the bank of china
the others include james biden a younger
brother of president joe biden a partial
copy of the subpoena was posted online
by the marco polo usa research group
headed by garrett ziegler who works as a
white house policy analyst under for who
worked as a white house policy analyst
under former president trump mr archer
was not aware of the specific subpoena
from 2019 which appears directed to a
bank his lawyer matthew schwartz told
the post in an email but mr archer has
cooperated completely with the delaware
us attorney's office investigation from
the moment he became aware of it so
they're looking into transactions
involving china the first thing i want
to say is uh look that there may be some
connection to hunter biden but if if you
were if you were to ask me do i think
anything in in terms of accountability
would happen to the biden family i would
say probably not
maybe if donald trump gets elected in
2024 but uh peter you seem to be much
more of an expert than i so what do you
think well i don't know you might be
right tim i think if the republicans
take the house and the senate you're
going to get congressional hearings they
some of those committees have subpoena
powers will they impeach joe biden i
think they should well they they marry
me very well i mean one of the things
that that troubled me the most in this
new book you know i did the first hunter
biden china stuff back in 2018 in a book
that i wrote and at that time it was a
story of like corruption and cronyism
and self-dealing and all that
what we did more recently for this book
is we went through the hundred biden
laptop and we went through some of the
emails of one of his business partners
who gave us access to his gmail account
and we wanted to figure out so
the biden's got all these deals in china
that hunter wasn't qualified for um who
actually made it rain right who actually
gave the bidens this money which is like
31 million dollars in deals so we traced
it back and what we found is that there
were four guys that set these deals up
every single one of these guys
has links to the highest levels of
chinese intelligence
so like one guy named chaefeng set him
up for a you know a 20 million dollar
payday
you know chaefeng at the time was
business partners with the vice minister
of state security who's in charge of
recruiting foreign spies for the chinese
you know
you can't make this i mean and and every
single case this was so you know
the the biden case no longer is just
cronyism and corruption i mean we have
to entertain the notion that the chinese
targeted the bidens they got the but
they got the bidens and that the bidens
are compromised you know it's an
intelligence operation i mean it has all
the markings of it isn't it crazy that
we spent so many years talking about
trump and russia yeah but now we're here
talking about biden and china yeah and
and and here you know unlike the trump
case when the trump stuff when the
dossier first came out
okay i fell for it and i was like hey we
gotta look at this like this looks
serious we got to investigate it and
then you know five or six mon months
later you realize this thing is
completely falling apart
but there you had no money right you had
this this anonymous dossier but you had
no money uh you had no deals you had no
you know links to intelligence with the
bidens you've got money nobody disputes
they got the 31 million dollars and now
you've got the fact that the people that
made these deals happen all have these
intelligence links so
it's completely compromised and i think
that congress needs to hold those
hearings and they need to get the bidens
under subpoena to testify in front of
congress
to explain it but i agree with you the
law enforcement
you know i've kind of given up on the
fact that they're going to hold these
these elites uh accountable there's a
different set of uh law and justice for
elites than there is for ordinary
americans and even as far as it can go
with the congressional hearing look
fauci lied under oath on numerous
occasions and nothing no accountability
no accountability you're exactly right
you look i think at this point
we look at all the past stories we've
already discussed this the split between
the left and the right
i think it's fair if i were to ask all
of you listening do you think when it
comes to you know say joe rogan or
anybody else that the left would be
willing to compromise and say oh okay
we'll we'll concede this point the
answer is of course not they won't
they'll keep pulling and pulling and
pulling it's only the right and the
liberty side that keeps conceding
in that capacity i think it's fair to
realize there will never be federal law
enforcement accountability for joe biden
and his family no matter how much gets
reported on it or anthony fauci no
matter how much it gets reported in
which case what ends up happening is it
doesn't matter if there's hard evidence
or not the republicans come in and
they'll be like oh we're going to
impeach why it's partisan yeah we we
discussed this with um
there was that pennsylvania story about
the judges striking down the mail and
voting law i don't know if you heard
that recently yeah and the judge
basically refused
to rule on it during the 2020 election
because they said you waited until after
your guy already lost to file this right
the judge had had decided because of
party affiliation he would not rule on
the merits because i assume your side is
just doing this to win if we're at the
point where a judge won't look at the
actual merits and we'll just say well
you're team a on team b so i say you
lose yeah well that's going to be that's
happening in law enforcement at what
point do people just say the system is
clearly broken there's not going to be
an accountability so it's going to be
law fair effectively if the if the you
know policy law fair whatever if the
republicans win the house and the senate
and they're going to impeach joe biden
for the sake of it but this time will
they be able to muster up enough to
actually get a conviction i'd wager
probably not it'll be the exact same
thing we saw and it's it's basically
just a tit-for-tat until finally the the
tower just crumbles and falls because
you know i don't know how our how our
country can sustain this kind of
hyper-partisan partisan
politic you know political attacks and
conflict you know yeah no it's i mean
it's scary i mean the scenario laid out
is is accurate and scary and part of it
is
there's not a sense i mean you guys
disagree with me obviously if you do
there just is not a sense of
truth with a capital t anymore and so
what do i mean it's like it's you know
in the case that you're talking about
the judge it's not a question of the
merits of of the case or the evidence
it's who's bringing
the facts and the evidence i mean i face
the same thing all the time people say
oh you know these are just right-wing
attacks against the bidens and i'm like
explain to me which of these facts are
right-wing i mean they're all from
chinese corporate documents and hong
kong financial records there's no
right-wing facts and left-wing facts
they're facts and you can debate them
and you can say whether they're accurate
but we've reached this point it's like
this post-truth
element where it doesn't really matter
whether it's true it's who's actually
bringing the evidence and i'm going to
attack the messenger rather than
actually deal with the underlying
evidence it's scary well i i it's it's
it's simple i mean i think jimmy dore is
a really great example the dude's
clearly economically and culturally left
but because he questions the
establishment he's right-wing yeah and
that's that's look you know they call me
right-wing and i'm like well look i'm
centrist so i can understand why they
view me and they'll say these things but
like come on jimmy's basically a
socialist and i don't mean that
disrespectfully i mean i think he calls
himself that and they're starting to
argue that he's like a right-wing
grifter right so clearly left and right
just means whose side it just means team
18b it doesn't even mean left and right
anymore yeah and there's that mattiabi
and and glenn greenwald are kind of in
the same boat i mean those guys are both
left-wing but because they actually want
to try to get to the truth
um they get hammered well uh truth has a
right-wing bias
that's right
yeah what was that colbert huh yeah yeah
nice try how much of a lie do we live in
right now how much truth can people
handle and what increments when we start
rolling out the truth
man
yeah you're getting philosophical yeah
we're built on the house of cards and if
we start moving these cards around
there's a chance the entire thing's
gonna this is one of the theories that
that a friend of mine uh who's in dc
former member of congress said you know
i said you know they won't have these
hearings on uh you know the origins of
covet and he said well of course they
won't and i said what do you mean of
course they won't he said because if
they actually come to the truth they'd
have to do something about it oh
yeah we um we had tom garrett on he
mentioned that when he was in congress
the republicans would come to him and be
like well don't actually support our
bill because then if we win what do we
have left you know and so there were
very much often stories like that or
stories of republicans being like oh we
can't support that bill they'll call us
racist yeah so it's remarkable how when
you learn how things are going behind
the scenes that
it's all one big joke it's one big game
being played well and this is why i mean
look at the rise you know like you and
joe rogan and some of the other people
out there i mean you obviously have to
be courageous what you're doing but part
of it is too you have a
basis of financial independence based on
the business that you've developed
and that's key i mean you think about
people that get cancelled um you know
people that that you know need to
fit into the establishment as part of
their business model if you don't have
that independence i mean you're screwed
and so you know when you're talking
about truth and how much truth do the
average americans want
you just look at leaders and and they
may know what the truth is uh but they
can't discuss it and enunciate it
because it could destroy their
livelihood they don't have the
independence that you have in other
people well i'll tell you one thing that
really drives a lot of these like left
activist types nuts is that
here we have no investors no big you
know institutional investors in any way
right and so there's always this
narrative of like oh this person is
funded by the koch brothers or the
mercers
and they they i've still i've seen
activists try to make that claim like he
must be getting funding from them and
it's like right no just regular people
are sick and fed up and have started to
fund conversations that they think you
know works for them for uh you know for
someone like joe rogan he just i i don't
think he runs any kind of membership
thing he's got ad revenue right but i'm
i'm pretty sure if you know the spotify
thing with rogan resulted in him getting
booted and he announced like sign up for
joe rogan premium yeah he'd be making a
hundred times ten times as much money
than he's making now right 100 million
dollar spotify deal with 11 million
listeners per episode imagine if he got
one percent to give 10 bucks per month
and they fear that joe could make it 120
20 million per year yeah just off of
that no they fear they fear that they
fear the fact that you've got
subscribers they fear that there are
these other independent sources of
information out there because they can't
get to the nub of it
and they can't eliminate it
and and that's really unfortunately what
the left wants is they want dominance
and here's the interesting question that
i would ask you because i have a theory
on this you know the left wants to shut
down debate
it comes from a position of you know
real cultural strength
but i think it it it really shows their
profound intellectual weakness
because if they really believe i mean
think about this they shut down all
these speakers from going on college
campus if they really felt like these
conservative speakers going on college
campus are these crazed you know you
know racists misogynist whatever i mean
i'd say like let them stand up there and
embarrass themselves but they don't want
to speak they don't want them to speak
because they know the power of the ideas
they are they are
fundamentally
lack confidence in their own ideas i
think also on top of that even if you
did hear that person's ideas and reject
them on their merits it wouldn't be good
enough for the left because they don't
want you to reject someone because you
thought for yourself and decided to
reject them they want you to reject
somebody because they told you to yeah
yeah you have to obey that's the point i
get that it's like a lot of people it
seems like a lot of people repeating
what they've been told when you talk
about the left and i see that in
religion sometimes people be like i read
it i was told this is real so this is
real and like that's different than when
you really believe something because
then you can debate it to anybody
yeah no that's exactly right you think
it through i mean to be somebody on the
left you can almost get there by osmosis
these days because the culture is
telling you
all these things if you're going to be
you know center right you really have to
think things through that's what's
really fascinating you know uh for the
longest time when all media was
controlled when there were only a few
broadcast towers to consume from there
was very little right-wing conversation
happening the establishment just
controlled it all and it was fairly
moderate left-leaning and slowly moved
drifting left with the rise of the
internet all of a sudden you ended up
with right-wing spaces areas where
individuals could now start speaking and
communicate and maintain their value
systems and that's been been an
impossibility for the left but with that
internet as well you end up with the
left moving 10 times faster than they
ever did pulling further and further
further to the left spiraling out of
control
but uh aside from that i'll just make
the point about joe rogan you know in
talking about what the left believes and
you know what what what jameis was
saying
everybody
it's it's almost pointless to even say
because so many people have made this
point already that none of these people
complaining about joe even watched
watches watch a show
they have no idea why they're mad right
and that's the scary thing and the
example i like to use is uh
this guy you know posted a meme a tweet
in reference to uh joe rogan and a guy
said in germany we have a saying
if there are 11 people at a table
and one of them is a nazi and the other
10 are talking to him you have 11 nazis
and uh and i mean that's a psychotic
statement because there's so much nuance
there is he there because it's a it's uh
you know did the nazi go to a meeting to
de-radicalize other 10 people like
former you know people trying to
de-radicalize them right but the
fascinating thing there is that the
point they're making about joe is that
it doesn't matter how many people he has
on that support the narrative if he
brings on one who doesn't it's all bad
and it must be you know just removed or
banned in germany the story i like to
bring up is when there was a journalist
and luke lukertkowski who was on the
show for a various amount of time and i
was in florida
he was walking down the street when
someone yelled randomly nazi schweinhund
and pointed at him as other journalists
so other random people who had no idea
who he was started physically attacking
him
another guy we know was a journalist and
someone screamed at him randomly nazi
schweinhund and so guys ran up jumped
him and started punching him in the head
and grabbed his camera from him and it's
like he's just some journalist guy
they they hurt these people luke got
beat up just randomly because someone
pointed and said those words that was
all it took for these these psychopaths
to physically harm other people
that is a cult yeah that that and that
is dangerous and when they all come out
and they're like joe rogan must be
banned and you go why because
what did he say i don't know right they
don't care they just want it done and
then i think the question is if 11
people being at a table and one of them
being a nazi means that all 11 are nazis
is daryl davis a klansman for going to
talk to people in the kkk and trying to
de-radicalize them do you see what
happened when daryl davis went to our
event no are you familiar with daryl
davis no he's a famous black jazz
musician who one day he said to himself
i don't understand how someone could
hate me if they don't even know me so he
went and actually met with white
supremacists and klansmen wow he went to
clan rallies and he actually talked to
him wow and then eventually these clan
guys started giving up the robes and
quitting and being like i never realized
these stories weren't true right amazing
so we had an event in in in the philly
suburbs called uh what was called ending
violence racism and authoritarianism
and it was like a generally classically
liberal event we had a bunch of people
across the political spectrum who all
agreed like hey these are things we
don't like
antifa showed up threatened to burn the
theater down we were forced to move it
to a smaller venue at a casino with more
security and daryl davis was our keynote
speaker
he got a standing ovation from the crowd
as he explained how his the robes had
been given to him
he he at the after party we still had it
across from the original theater because
the people who ran that a venue were
unwilling they were like we're not going
to back down
and when antifa was outside and the
police were blocking it daryl was like
i'm going to go out and talk to these
guys because you know that's his view
he did it with the club they started
screaming at him nazi and racist and
white supremacist and they would not
listen to a word he said and then he
made a post on facebook that went viral
where he said i cannot believe this
that he he he posted this story how he
said he could walk up to a clan meeting
and they would they would talk to him
and tell them what they believed but
these far left antifa types just yelled
at him and refused to talk at all and he
was shocked by it
so to answer to answer to respond to
your point yes
yeah they very much view him as far
right and nazi and all that stuff in
fact he's been smeared because the
klansmen give him the robes and he keeps
them and he shows everybody look what
they've given up and they're like aha
he's got it that proves oh my gosh it's
so insane
but how do we live with like
you know when you have a massive cult
like that i mean
look i'll make this point too to these
leftists they they they insult and smear
you know the white christian male
sheamus and i do not believe
there's a lot of things we don't yeah
james is very very religious i'm not but
here we are having conversations we get
along we're good friends how is it that
we all found a way to live together
but these these people are absolutists
and don't accept that you know what i
mean yeah yeah i mean
if you look at history the the thing
that sticks out to me most are the
maoists right in the cultural revolution
which was um it was you weren't
discussing anything you weren't asking
people to explain anything they would go
through and the village and if they saw
somebody that had uh uh reading glasses
you know they'd immediately say well
you're an intellectual you're you're a
threat you know they would throw them in
prison based on simple things like that
if you had books you know you're a
threat to the state and and it's this
this this inability to even have a
conversation uh to try to understand the
other person and it shows it's really
not about a care about people it's about
this this um you know cultic belief
system that we have you know i get
nervous when i think about mao's
revolution and they all were targeting
what they called rightists yes they were
big on getting
weeding out the right and i don't want
to find ourselves in the same position
inadvertently
weeding out the leftists like
making the other out of this idea of a
leftist where because that's exactly
what mao was doing
so i i don't want to divide people in
that sense i understand there is a
psychosis going around right now but you
know uh ian i i hear you and i agree
with you but i also want to make the
point that you know i made earlier that
there's there's a hard line
when
the left for the most part is completely
i would say almost that is is almost
absolute in their belief structure they
don't listen to joe rogan's podcast but
they want him purged they they they go
around and destroy and smash up
businesses and burn down buildings and
as long as you know someone like you is
constantly saying like oh we shouldn't
demonize these people and we should
figure out a way to like you know avoid
that conflict they're gonna say thank
you for conceding and giving us more
power we'll exploit you for that maybe
it could be punish the behavior but not
the people
well and i would also say too i mean to
tim's point you have this hardcore
element that does this and then you have
what used to be called fellow travelers
right these are the guys that kind of
went along and they're not as is
strongly committed and maybe those are
the ones you're talking about the big
question though is tim i don't know what
you think about this is you know what
portion of the of the left are hardcore
left and what portion are followers i
mean can any of them be be persuaded
uh i i do think if we look at the
polling data we mentioned i mentioned
this earlier yeah we're seeing an
erosion from we're seeing a larger
portion of democrat aligned individuals
becoming republican as opposed to the
opposite right that
it shows the democratic party is eroding
i don't think the republican party is
the solution i do think the people that
are joining the republicans are doing
out of frustration and looking for some
kind of meaningful opposition they're
not going to find but you know
i i think that's the difference the
people who are in the democratic
alignment are probably default liberal
followers or willfully ignorant and
willfully going along with it
the issue is
you know
here's here's the point i was making
earlier ian
the chinese communist party is absolute
if you oppose the chinese communist
party you must be stopped at all costs
in the united states we're allowed to
speak out and and smack talk our leaders
and our politicians we're allowed to
insult the democratic party to great to
a great extent
so that
good will that we are allowed that
freedom is exploited by the
authoritarians they say thank you now we
will use that fact to fund dissent in
your country and erode it so when we're
dealing with groups of people that are
absolutists and i'll give you another uh
something to think about
these people on the left call you
far right
and they're unwilling to tolerate you
they they they would call you an
extremist or alt-right or whatever like
that you know that one guy who was on
joe's show keeps doing and and and you
keep trying to say well let me extend
that olive branch well they're taking
two steps back you take two steps before
they take two steps back again and
you're like i'm trying guys i'm trying
like hey come on come on come on keep
keep coming keep coming i know where
this leads more cameron anvil this is
this is an old carthaginian tactic i'm
going to be surrounded pretty soon if i
keep coming towards you that's right
yeah yeah so at a certain point you just
say i'm going to stop right here i'm
going to stay here look you know for the
longest time the republican party has
very much been like we're going to stop
and stand right here and it hasn't
worked the gun control is the best
example right every day the democrats
say we want to ban more guns and they
keep doing it the activists respond
saying ian no one's trying to take your
guns we're just being reasonable and
then you show a picture of waco and say
this has been going on for decades but
where is any republican to be like unban
the guns yeah there's no so it's it's
just constantly being pulled in the
direction of authoritarian couldn't i
just be like keep offering the olive
branch and then when they all come out
like ha ha now you're surrounded i'll be
like yeah and explode into super and
then they'll all like find the love
that's kind of like no but um one one
option is to plant yourself like a tree
and say these are my principles i will
not move but the olive olive branch is
available to you anytime you come here
and knock on my door
so i will not keep saying like you know
look they want to ban joe rogan why
don't we offer a concession and just put
warning label no no no no no no no if
you don't like it you know joni mitchell
and neil young and and nils lofgren
you're free to leave they did i respect
it thanks have a nice day yeah because
here's the thing first is the warning
labels they're not going to be satisfied
with that they'll move on to the next
thing and the next thing and that's
that's invariable gun control is a great
example of that or the warning labels
are proof yeah you see we were right
they're even admitting now that it's
misinformation ban it right right
exactly peter i have somewhat of an
answer to your question it's not perfect
it's not airtight but it's just based on
my experiences when you're sort of
asking how many of these people are just
regular democrats and how many of them
are extremists
so again small sample size and a biased
sample size okay
but i went to an art school
and the politics were generally very
left-leaning
however
every left-leaning person and i mean
really far to the left leaning person
who i spoke with one-on-one or had
conversations with behind closed doors
or happened to hang out with
were much more willing to entertain
conversations that would have been
forbidden to them when other people
weren't around and they were more likely
to tell jokes that would be considered
offensive or laugh at jokes that i told
that would be considered offensive they
were more likely to go there with you
and i think it's no mystery because
leftism is fundamentally a collectivist
philosophy that lefties are kind of only
lefties when there's more than one of
them around if you catch one of these
people by themselves they're so much
more reasonable but as soon as they get
into a group they will not entertain
anything you tell them and i've had
conversations with left-leaning people
where i got them to admit things and
accept things that they would never
acknowledge in front of a group of
people ever i was the battle uh the
battle of berkeley
i was at a bunch of them i can't
remember which one this one was but it
was the one where uh that that young
woman got punched in the face and that
video went viral yeah and there was this
one guy who was in a video with her and
after everything was like dispersing and
people were fleeing i started talking to
him i was asking him you know about
what's going on he showed me his knife
and he's like i gotta bring my knife man
because these people are far right you
know they're fascists and all that stuff
and i was like you think the people in
that park are fascists and he was like
yeah dude and he this is this is this is
an antifa guy by himself and i was like
yo
see that group right there and he's like
yeah and i'm like yo that's like 90 old
women
and he was like well yeah but they're
like fascists because like the older
generation man they're like racists and
stuff and i was like yeah but come on
like you think they're gonna go and like
pull out guns and knives and you need a
knife to stop them like they're old
ladies and he was like well
you know it's just for protection
and then i was like and look at that you
see that you see that that flag right
there says come and take it and he's
like yeah and i was like these people
are
afraid
that a fascist tyrannical government
will oppress them
so they don't want their guns taken from
them right and he goes
well i mean i don't know uh and i was
like no no like right they say they say
don't take my guns let me keep my guns
and he goes yeah they want their guns
and i was like and they say it's because
they're scared of a tyrannical
government taking over and it's like
yeah and i'm like so it sounds like
they're actually anti-fascist
he was like
well i guess but like they're racist and
stuff and i was like well it sounds like
they want to be left alone from a
traditional government same as you maybe
if you like talk to them and figure
things out there was one leftist guy who
actually showed up to that event and he
was like a hippie and he was wearing
hippie clothes and he was like i love
free speech and i was like what do you
think about the people here's like ah
they're all racists and he was in the
park though and he was like but it's
good that people are coming out
expressing their free speech and i'm
willing to talk to them and tell them
they're wrong and i was like hey man
yeah right on that's what it's all about
but these other guys you know when
you isolate these people that's how they
get away with it they isolate these
young activists
fill their hands with lies and then tell
them don't talk to them because they'll
lie to you and they're grifters and
they'll try and trick you and then these
people get scared and you know the other
thing is cancel culture isn't about
canceling the right to a great degree a
lot of people on the right are the left
is trying to censor us and that's true
it's true but one thing one part of
canceled culture you need to understand
is that it's that it's an enforcement
for the cultural left on the cultural
left
if you are a leftist and you speak out
we will come for you so shut your mouth
and do as you're told
it's not just the right for the most
part they're they're defiant they're
like screw you bad me and they get
banned
the cancel culture makes fear among the
ranks of default liberals where they're
like look i can't speak up i'll lose my
job
so part of this uh what you were talking
about sheamus of this pack and tim you
seem to have the same experience you
think this fact that the more intolerant
is a group that's a function of this
enforcement mechanism you're talking
about and maybe there's a little bit of
virtue signaling there as well right you
don't want to admit around your friends
that that uh you know the other person
has common sense is there anything more
to it than that
i don't know i mean i so i had a friend
reach out to me during the nick sandman
debacle and they were very on the left
and i always knew them as a left-winger
and they said
i
think this is insane the people i'm
surrounded within close to all think
it's completely normal and then there's
part of me that wonders do they like
you're reaching out to me because you
know i'm your right-leaning friend maybe
they're reaching out to their like
right-leaning friend and saying the
exact same thing i i gotta tell you it
is absolutely mind-boggling having
one-on-one conversations with like
critical race theory lefty types
when when their brains just break
you know and you're like did mar you
know i the question i always ask them is
do you believe are you a fan of you know
martin luther king jr say yes do you
agree with with his dream speech that
one day his four little children will be
judged on the content of the character
of the color of their skin like
absolutely and then i'm like so do you
think it's right to judge people based
on the color of their skin or to view
them based on their race principally and
they're like yes and then i'm just like
doesn't that kind of contradict that
statement you just look well you got to
understand the nuances of what dr king
really meant and i'm like i'm pretty
sure he did not mean that we should be
judging people like he said it pretty
explicitly but that's the question i
always start with because i'll be like
you know i tell people like look
you don't need to lie to me and claim
you like dr king out of some social
moral obligation
it's absolutely okay if you want to come
out and tell me you think he was wrong
i'm not going to get mad at you for it
we'll have a conversation about it but
because it is socially unacceptable to
oppose the teachings of dr king and some
of them were good and some of them were
bad i mean he's not a perfect guy or
anything like that that these people
simultaneously hold contract reviews the
modern view is that racial
identitarianism among the left is is a
mandate but also dr king is a mandate as
well but they clash right you know the
derrick bell is not a fan of those
ideologies and that's critical race
theory yeah so in a way malcolm x one
right the the the debate between martin
luther king jr and malcolm x and the x
in the 60s about you know how the black
community should go forward critical
race theory is basically malcolm x one
that racial identity is key
element to who you are as a person it's
remarkable that um
we still live in a society where
everyone recognizes that racial
identitarianism is wrong but the left
routinely somehow advances the cause of
racial identitarianism and they and
these these these left activists more
pronounced democrat types simultaneously
hold or espouse both views at the same
time yeah well and also certain racial
identities are good right i mean nobody
would i don't think anybody in in normal
conversation would say that that you
know white identity politics are good um
and they're not but there's an
acceptance of black identity politics
and it seems to be contradictory to me i
mean you can't you know you have to have
a consistent principle here identity
politics in in many ways is i think
neutral but it's the authoritarian
application of identity politics too
that you know it's hard to actually
quantify a lot of ways right the civil
rights movement identity politics
certainly it's it's it was a good thing
and there were some bad elements to it
there was violence there were riots of
course and you know we don't like a lot
of that but uh you know we want to point
out that if there is a racial disparity
that we're like okay well that's a
problem how do you solve it well the
answer isn't more racism right the
answer is typically class-based or
education based or something like that
but uh i think critical race theory
woke-ism and these ideas are just used
as a cudgel by the left because they
know people
it is socially acceptable to say martin
luther king jr was correct and to oppose
that you'll be viewed as a racist people
don't want to be a racist so the left
just decided we can use this as a cudgel
to beat anyone who opposes us and to
scare them yeah well now we're at the
point where they're like you're a racist
you're a racist and everyone's just like
i shut up just you're it's meaningless
but but as i was saying you know cancel
culture very much is is for the left
they want to make sure anybody on the
left is scared to speak out they're
scared to come on shows like this
because if they did i'll tell you what
we've invited people on the left come on
the show and they would uh some have
agreed to but but then at the last
minute refused to
and um you know without saying who
specifically i might have already said
this in the past but i'll just say
without without saying who
i think it's because if we got one of
these leftists on the show with say alex
jones or steve bannon they would be
saying you're right steve you're right
steve i agree steve steve you're also
correct and then all of a sudden people
would say aha they agree with everything
steve bannon said they're their right
wing exactly even though steve bannon's
a populist and espouses many things like
tax the rich the left already agrees
with right yeah well and they eat each
other and they know that people in their
in-group will single them out and say
this person isn't ideologically pure
enough i have a clip of them sitting
across from tim pool saying i agree with
that point he agreed with tim poole on
something he needs to be purged from the
movement it's like it's like i pointed
out in that meme you know the guy says
in germany if there's 11 people one's a
nazi and the 10 are talking to him you
have 11 nazis that's why the left is
scared of cancel culture and and this
enforcement and that's why they don't
come on these shows uh it's like that
it's that meme that any sufficiently
unmoderated forum will become right-wing
right that's what happens on the
internet if you have five people on a
podcast and one of them is tim poole all
five of them are tim poole
the way the way i describe it is that
politics only flows in one direction
if uh if you have if you have an
anti-foot member and a proud boy and
they're sitting there having a
conversation and drinking beers they're
both proud boys
there's no instance where the proud boys
or the right is going to be like that
proud boy secretly antifa they're going
to be like why is he talking antifa and
the left is going to be like two proud
boys
so it only flows in one direction
so where that ends up um i mean honestly
it sounds like the left loses
because they'll just excise all of their
members until there's nothing left well
exactly and so one thing you said
earlier which is a white pill and which
i wholeheartedly agree with is that the
corrupt authority structure of the
chinese government is actually quite
brittle because when you are
corrupt of course that means that your
structure has less integrity and so
ultimately even though i'm not like out
to lunch here i'm not saying there's
nothing to be done i'm not saying
there's no threat i think there is some
assurance in the fact that at the end of
the day goodness and truth do triumph
and i firmly believe that
well they do and i think if you look at
history i mean uh tyrants have done
really well uh for some time but
eventually people get fed up right they
get fed up with it and the concentration
of power this is the thing that i always
get excited about right the the thing
that that fuels
my desire to investigate corruption and
the way that i view the world is i just
have this profound distrust of people
having a lot of power now sometimes it's
necessary right you're fighting a war
you're fighting the nazis in world war
ii you got to have generals you got to
have political leaders that have a lot
of power in order to win the battle that
sometimes happens but in normal peaceful
time
i don't want to have people that have a
lot of power over my life and i'm
particularly suspicious of people in
government doesn't mean that that
corporate power isn't a huge problem but
i you know generally bill gates can't
force me to do anything i mean you can
try to persuade me to buy windows
products and he got he can't compel me
to do anything the government can compel
me to do stuff
those are the ones i really fear and i
think a lot of people have have come
there a lot of dissolution people on the
left were given they were sold all these
promises of what government was going to
be able to do for them and help them and
of course we want government to help
people in ways that it can but it's been
so disappointing in the promises that
they offered and they've never delivered
and that's what's exciting when people
start thinking about that's you know you
look at canada what's going on those
truckers didn't think hey i want to go
on a 600 mile drive to ottawa just for
the hell of it i've never seen ottawa
before they're animated because their
government's failed them and they're
tired of it must have been crazy when
they were getting gas
that's hilarious i'm sure the price went
up in canada just from all the truckers
driving
well you know eventually they all got to
pull in and they're all fueling up and
maybe some of them get in line in
intervals and stuff but probably you
know yeah no i think i i would
piggybacking off of what you're saying
and how there are some people who really
do believe that the government is is
there to take care of them and sort of
contrasting that to either a very
cynical attitude or maybe even an
optimistic attitude like the the one
that we share when it comes to truth and
goodness
the naive person looks at
a corrupt system
and says it's not going to affect me
it's not going to hurt me the cynical
person says it's going to hurt me and
there's nothing i can do about it it's
going to continue to hurt other people i
think the optimistic person says this
might hurt me but in the long run
everything is going to be okay even if i
don't end up being comfortable with my
life even if i die ultimately truth will
prevail
you know what scares me is the idea of
survival at all costs
you know that people are willing to just
sit back and say let the machine do as
it pleases as long as i can just make it
another day yeah
sometimes you got to take risks man and
cynicism does it's funny because nevitae
does that but cynicism also does that
because a person says there's nothing i
can do to fight this it's going to win
right i get nervous about the idea of
truth
um
i find it so subjective i know we have
this conversation from time to time
objective or subjective truth every
episode every when you zoom out the
further you zoom out the less things are
what you thought they were and you
realize that i'm just defining the
you know reality with this form of truth
when if i zoom out i can redefine it
it's the same reality both truths are
right which one do we adhere to and so i
don't want to get obsessed with the
truth
because i think that that can be
weaponized there's a there's a good
comic where it's two guys and there's a
six or a nine depending on which way
you're standing and they're both looking
from different angles pointing down
saying six and the guy's saying nine
yeah they're both right well i don't
know because somebody painted a six or a
nine there and intended it to be
recognized six or nine somebody painted
a sideways symbol knowing it would be
confusing and disruptive and that person
was the chinese communist party
ah you got me on there
i mean i would say obviously i'm always
going to argue in favor of objective
truth and it's a bigger discussion for
the after show but
because i think ultimately what you're
saying is even the claim you're making
about zooming out is a truth claim
you're saying the truth of it is when we
zoom out it looks like this so you still
believe in truth but i want to ask you
something here peter because
the the thing i really wanted to pick
your brain about here is obviously you
study political corruption a lot
what would you say is something that
myself
ian tim lydia and the people in the
audience probably haven't considered
about corruption or some particularly
corrupt elements within the system that
aren't paid enough attention to oh man
that's a good question i think there's a
lot more corruption than people realize
and it's not this sort of abstract
people kind of think that you know
they're guys taking you know money and
shoeboxes and they're more sophisticated
about that there's the biggest
corruption in washington the most
profitable corruption in washington dc
is legal corruption
it's stuff that you can actually do and
get away with and the problem is the
political class gets to write their own
rules right i mean you've got a business
you're in business tim you've got a
business we don't get to write our own
rules we have to conform with what the
laws tell us the the politicians they
get to write their own rules so um that
to me is i think the biggest concern
that we all have to have is people
always say to me well is it illegal
and the af the answer a lot of times is
well it'd be illegal if we did it but
it's not if they do it because they got
to write the rules and they wrote it
that way and the you know the insider
trading on the stock market is the is
the classic example of this
um it was legal for a long time for
members of congress to do it and then i
wrote a book called throw them all out
exposed it we did a big 60 minutes
episode they confronted nancy pelosi
with you know all the stuff that she was
doing and then they passed a law because
people so outraged they passed a law
called the stock act that was supposed
to fix it
and then about four or five months later
in the house and the senate they had a
voice vote so nobody recorded the vote
to gut the bill
and barack obama in the middle of the
night there was no rose garden ceremony
like there was the last time signed it
and they totally gutted it so it's
bipartisan and and what you find a lot
of times is a lot of the combat you see
going on in washington dc these guys are
yelling at that guy it's a little bit
like professional wrestling we're going
to have marjorie taylor green back on
the show and she made an excellent uh
well she just she told us something that
was you know shocking to a lot of people
that democrats or republicans just sit
in a room where they're like okay we got
a bill here in favor democrats aye
republicans nay democrats get it bang
the gavel moving on there's no they
don't count the votes they don't
actually go through it they don't debate
it it's just like bang next bang next
what's up
where do they go oh can i hear all the
yays they're like yeah all the nays yeah
the ass have it so we've got to do it we
gotta go to nashville
we gotta go to super chats we are way
late if you haven't already smash that
like button subscribe to this channel
for every like we get it is one hunk in
support of the trucker convoy one like
one hunk and go to timcast.com we're
gonna have a members only podcast up
around 11 or so pm you're not gonna
wanna miss it this is where we we're not
so family-friendly and uh definitely
check that out at timcast.com i can't
read the name of the first super check
that's how youtube works they say the
great honking knows no borders not
between nations and not between real
life and the internet and then there's a
whole bunch of truck emojis and some
horns
yeah i love how so many the chats are
just honk honking yeah yeah everyone's
just chatting already
everybody chant honk
show us uh neil williams says show us
your hunkers
all right it's fun watching these videos
man you know people are like looking out
their window and you're just honking and
wailing and i'm like dude i dig it man
dark world noted to be at the beginning
of the show 1.7 k to 4.6 k likes in 60
seconds because i posted one like equals
one hunk everybody is hilarious
all right let's see rylo says tim can
you please clarify when normal people
cede ground to authoritarians we are
cowards but when rogan does it it's tact
ps the freedom convoys must outlast
government else it will fail uh certain
circumstances are seating ground and
certain circumstances are tacked and
certain circumstances are literally both
joe rogan is quite literally being
tactful and seeding ground i think
there's reason to criticize but there's
also a conversation to be had about
spotify's shares recovered after he made
the ass after he made the announcement
he gives some ground to the left if we
keep doing this as so this is literally
what i said in in the segment if the
right if if there are 100 grains of sand
on the right and 100 grains of sand on
the left and we keep saying well to
avoid losing 10 grains of sand the right
will give up but one it's tactful
strategy it's a strategic loss but if
that is the only path forward after you
know 10 years the right has no grains of
sand left it's one tiny grain of sand we
don't think it's that big of a deal my
point is that it may be beneficial in
the long run to to retreat because
retreat in battle is sometimes the right
move but you can't only retreat so it
could be both it really really can
i mention this on this show too you know
and i've said not everybody can just up
and leave their job i totally understand
that some people probably should and
some people might have to recognize that
some you know life will be very
difficult to do what they can but i
recognize that everybody could and i
recognize that we're under constraints
as well which is why we created a
speakeasy as it were where we talk about
what we can on this show which is most
things that one percent we can't we have
over at timcast.com and we're starting
to put up on podcast platforms where we
don't so actually putting up about
we put up one uncensored show on sundays
now on that it's because we want to get
those conversations out and bypass the
censorship i'm sorry man it's it's not
easy it's not perfect and i'm not i'm
certainly not perfect you know but i try
all right
siggy says i am a lady truck driver in
alabama we stand with our northern
northern brethren thanks for all those
who show appreciation for drivers we get
a lot of ish
yeah definitely man
all right jay benning says i was at the
vancouver support protest this weekend i
was pessimistic thinking was just a
small group of us against the mandates
driving through it gave me hope warms
your heart yeah man so there's a uh all
these people online these lefty liberal
types are complaining they're like it's
so noisy and they're harassing me it's
like
yo in 2012 there was something called
the casseroles protest where people all
across canada were going outside banging
pots and pans and it was super noisy and
loud
and they were like yay and i'm like i'm
down for either of it's non-violence and
disobedience man do your thing also to
quote aoc when people were burning
buildings down protests are supposed to
make you a little uncomfortable that's
right and it's honking man but it's
funny because like it's three days of
non-stop honking
earplugs man i mean look
when the extinction rebellion people
blocked the road in dc i i defended it i
said hey look it's non-violence
obedience those who make peaceful
revolution inevitable i'm sorry uh
impossible make violent revolution
inevitable so people need to have that
medium between destruction and
obstruction and if a handful of people
are like i want to get my message out
there so they block a road okay the cops
come in they remove them we say you're
going to get criminally charged for this
but we tolerate that level because we
don't want people throwing firebombs
right so there's got to be some you know
some level
all right let's let's we got what's this
alex says it wasn't just ottawa honking
happened in every city in canada on
saturday confirmed y v r y x x y e g y c
y y z and y h z with video from friends
and family reddit city subs confirmed
whiners and all the rest wow interesting
canadians yeah man people standing up
where they believe in great respect
brownie ninja says video idea for
sheamus rich clones of two people run
everything the millie o'neil and billy
o'neil bernie is complaining that they
are to blame for everything until the
millies start to fawn over him because
they love his book he turns into a
million blames billy's oh my gosh no
it's i mean it's it's legit it's true
that's literally exactly what happened i
have to think about that i just have to
make sure that this person doesn't sue
me when i take their idea i'll have to
get them to sign an nda or something
it's like bernie was like everybody we
have to break into the mansion
and then the moment he got to the door
and knocked on it they were like bernie
just screw those guys come on in the
clock and he's like i can come in you're
in the club bro he's a million bucks uh
just a minute everybody i have to go
inside this building real quick and then
they close the door and everyone's
outside when you write a best-selling
book you can have that's like well
whatever that's what what about the
people who like gathered the lumber and
then turned it into paper and that like
there's so many people who worked at
their jobs to make that book happen
besides you bernie why are you the
millionaire there's that uh family guy
episode where
everyone's complaining about the
supermarket taking taking jobs and
destroying the the town's economy or
whatever so peter's like let's go
protest and then he walks in the air
conditioning and then like then he walks
outside he goes you are trespassing on
private property
that's what it is
you know
all right
let's see what we got matt b says a
canadian i'm proud of these guys who are
in ottawa and provincial buildings also
name the last protest you've seen where
people were shoveling the sidewalks and
trucker were removing graffiti
yet uh toronto's son says waving nazi
and confederate flags and stealing food
from homeless people you know what i
really love about that trope we have to
feed the homeless you hear that and i'm
like dude they're not foodless they're
homeless right some of the a lot of the
homeless people in the united states are
very fat yeah you know so we need to
home the homeless
that was always the funniest thing to me
because i worked for non-profits and i'm
just like yo why are we feeding people
who don't have homes why don't we give
them homes yeah and they're like i don't
know they're hungry and i'm like how do
you know they're hungry they're homeless
not foodless and also technically these
truckers would be homeless right in
ottawa because their homes aren't there
that's right there you go so they're
without home temporarily no
all right
clayton says friday sheamus said god's
word hasn't been changed god had rules
for slavery wait for sheamus to respond
because he'll falsely claim it was
indentured servitude when there were
distinctions between jewish servants and
heathen slaves need matt dillahunty on
yeah so it's a good question you have
the old covenant you have the new
covenant so you have laws that were
specific to the jewish people based on
god's covenant with them as opposed to
the natural law of the universe so
what i was talking about basically is
that there are certain immutable moral
laws of the universe that do not change
and cannot change based on circumstance
so something
like
marriage falls into that category
because thou shalt not commit adultery
as a commandment so there has to be some
sort of parameter for that when it comes
to the way the old testament discusses
that when you had wars people would be
captured as prisoners of war sometimes
people would owe a debt and so they
would work it off it was not the same as
the kind of chattel slavery that we
refer to but nonetheless the church
condemns
slavery and owning other people
you guys need to have a special
conversation on religion that we could
put up on the website i mentioned that
last time but that would be that would
be great so if yeah no
time and we just put up for free we have
like you know religious conversation
with the
hippie dmt ian and you know sheamus
religious all right let's read some more
we got james also wait can i mention one
thing too though um christianity was so
from its inception so anti-slavery
that st patrick who was taken a slave by
the irish went back evangelized ireland
and within decades of his death slavery
had almost completely disappeared
in ireland because the people had
accepted christianity wow yeah you guys
should have a longer conversation yeah
yeah let's read some more we got uh jay
nabor says old fat truck driver from
dubuque here sheamus cartoon idea next
panda pandemic is the lying pants on
fire virus talking head saying things
with burning coming up from below then
alex jones says something and nothing
happens let's go canada
all right thank you all these people are
just writing my tunes for me and they're
super chat again i'm gonna say
i will let you guys know i know they're
paying tim guys pay me no i so i i do
have a trucker convoy cartoon that i'm
very excited to work on and i'm very
excited to to show everybody i can't
wait for thursday
braden hitchener says the guy with the
confederate flag is against the movement
most likely illiterate in history and
thought the confederate flag is
incriminating to bring bad press the
entire movement i will say there was um
what was i forgot the guy's name he's
the canadian hero who traveled across
the country when he was sick
what was his name terry something terry
terry fox
uh i'm not as well versed on canadian
history but there was a statue and they
put the flag on them and the mandate
freedom and everyone you know people got
really mad about that and i'm very much
of the uh i i got they didn't vandalize
it they just put a flag on him in a cape
or whatever but you know my opinion is
you got to be very very careful right
about you know because there are people
who are sitting at home are probably
confused as much as i don't think there
are a lot of regular people that aren't
politically active these days there are
some you know and they're going to be
like
you've got to be you've got to be the
people who are shoveling the snow and
cleaning up graffiti and you're waving
to people with smiles on your faces as
opposed to the rambunctious
also i want to mention this isn't it the
purpose of a journalist to investigate a
story instead of going oh this is
something that i want to have seen
happen so i'm going to report that it
did like shouldn't they be asking
questions about who this person with a
confederate flag is yes right you think
yep or why there's one guy with a nazi
flag and then all of a sudden all the
stories are like protesters we're waving
nazi flags it's like there was one guy
there man nobody liked him
there was a there was a viral video of a
guy who showed up at a patriot prayer
event in i think near portland who had
some kind of like i think a nazi flag or
something and he was or he was yelling
the n-word and all the left was like see
this proves it and i'm like yo it's
literally a video of the right-wing
group kicking him out yeah yeah
i was like i don't understand what this
it proves they're racist and they're
like yeah well he's with him and i'm
like but they're kicking him out don't
care if 11 people are kicking one nazi
out you have 12 nazis
all right dennis says back in july last
year when churches were being burned
down trudeau said it was a shame but
understandable now it's unacceptable and
disgusting to honk your horn for freedom
one like equals one honk
honk that like button like like that
honk a button yeah like hit that smash
that horn yes that's what the honk
button is hit it put the like button we
are change super chat it doesn't say
have you guys ever heard of bill gates
bill gates
who's that started apple no but i heard
this guy named luke who used to be on
this podcast
bill gates luke leaves the show and now
he has to pay us to say things on the
show
opportunity cost
our plan is complete
oh this is cool
radioactive llama says viva fry was live
streaming from the protest today for
hours what he was showing didn't match
with what trudeau said at all it is
infuriating but we have awesome content
creators commentators and youtubers like
viva fry you guys should definitely
subscribe to his channel who goes out
and actually shows you the truth that
that is is the power of the internet
that's the positivity of the internet
there are bad things there's
manipulation but that helps us break
through the lies tim speaking of luke
super chat can we ask one question about
bill gates and if there's any kind of
connection to china there's something
you could say about the corruption
given your research oh man yeah there's
a big section on bill gates uh bill
gates loves china he uh thinks president
xi works very hard
uh for the chinese people he's an
advisor to xi he's a member of this
thing called the china
engineering
association
and it's an advisory body to the
government he's invested in a lot of
companies that help build up the chinese
military
it's a huge problem microsoft uh is very
involved in artificial intelligence
research in china in laboratories where
the chinese military is doing that work
and in fact microsoft takes interns
from the people's liberation army so
it's it's it's a it's a crazy
relationship and uh bill gates is is one
of those uh guys who
likes the chinese model very well that's
crazy i had no idea he was an advisor to
xi jianping yeah yep wow i just want to
wow i want to point out how much i love
the word hunk
so good i got to read this one many
strange cork says give me liberty or
give me hunk
to honk or not to honk that is the
question
i regret i have
i have one honk to give to my country
let's win one for the hulk
i'll i'll be your huncle berry
that was a good one
oh my god tonka palooza 2022.
it it works out so well because of the
honk meme already with like clown world
and now the truckers and now the
you know honking yeah i like that one i
regret i have but one honk to give my
country
you don't you can actually you can honk
several times and keep doing it i had a
friend once who got a ticket for
improper use of horn in chicago oh yeah
it's just because what is that what is
that honking yeah you can't honk for any
reason other than like to alert someone
new york's got this too
just because they're so highly urbanized
they don't want to disturb the piece
yeah i don't think that's he was he was
honking to like his friend was in the
house and he pulled up and honked to let
him know he's there and it's like
and he got a ticket for you and the cop
was like you can't do that
it's like a 35 dollar ticket or
something improper use of horn
of honk
i remember as a kid you know the
truckers would go by on the road and
you'd like you know you want them to
honk right you'd want that's a big part
of it yeah
jazz monkey says my friends and i were
serving truckers and police coffee and
police coffee at the protest there's
lots of love in the air and conservative
leaders are meeting and speaking with
truckers in spite of the limp wristies
to tyrant trudeau
wrists jordan peterson made a call to uh
political uh members of the canadian
political
affiliate i don't know how you would
describe it but hey let's get it going
this is your moment this is your time to
shine the citizens are behind you come
on well i mean one super chat we had
earlier was mentioning that the the
convoy was just still getting into
ottawa and it was backed up and more and
more people are coming i want it all
through united states man bring it but
it's very much like occupy yeah it's a
populist protest people in the united
states yeah truckers should look here's
the crazy thing
if you're in a truck and you pull into a
city and you're legally allowed to drive
there it is very obstructive to that
city but no one is doing anything that
borders on any illegality right so the
interesting thing is when you take a
boat
like extinction rebellion did and put it
in the middle of a intercept of an
intersection you're blocking traffic
move we refuse you're under arrest
if everybody just drove their trucks
into the city and just jammed everything
up it's literally just people driving on
roads yeah there's nothing they can do
other than everyone go and you go okay
and you just turn left and you go back
around yeah and it's like what are they
gonna do they can't do anything about it
well and the other thing about truckers
and the significance of this protest is
they're not exactly a group of people
which is generally outspoken there are
certain careers which i will not name
that are sort of notorious for
complaining about how underappreciated
and undervalued they are truckers are
extremely important and you don't see
them going out there
flaunting their stuff all the time
talking about how people need to be more
considerate of them talking about how
people need to appreciate them more so
when they're willing to stand up and say
we're drawing a line all right treat us
with some decency and respect probably
listen not just because they bring you
your food but also because this is not a
group of people which is constantly
making demands on us i hate to be a
debbie downer on this one but i imagine
people like klaus schwab are going this
is very good for us
the truckers won't bring food in
then people will stop spending money and
capitalism will fail
they need our thrones
but i just because i think
the securing of the right of the worker
will be better for capitalism in the
long run
yeah yeah in the short term i can
imagine great reset people are like you
know truckers if they're not working and
bringing stuff in then we're resetting
everything it's working yeah but in the
long run if the people actually win and
the corrupt system fails and it doesn't
matter what they want exactly well you
think about ein rand's book you know
atlas shrugged i don't know if you guys
have read it or you heard about it but
yeah but it was a nine-hour long movie
about it exactly exactly i mean but the
whole premise of the story was like all
the people that make things happen in
society kind of you know the smart
business basically go on strike and
leave yeah like in this case it's the
truckers doing it right yeah and they're
the ones that are actually delivering
the food because they make it happen
they don't realize how important they
are yeah that's like if your blood left
your body yeah yeah yeah that's what
people need to realize new york man
these cities
i i just i wish
even for like one week all the truckers
were like we're not gonna go into new
york city yeah that's what i would have
no food i want people to experience what
it would be like without them without
actually taking it away from them
because i don't want to cause the
suffering
it's gonna it's like a horrible horrible
amount of suffering i would imagine
would come out of that if that were to
happen there's a question about what it
takes for someone to truly learn a
lesson
and if these people keep voting in
policies that are destroying the lives
of everyone in this country because of
new york
right i'll put it this way if the people
of new york keep voting in nationally
and federally the same people who then
vote for policies that negatively impact
people who live in the country who don't
want anything to do with their way of
life there comes a time where it's like
if the truckers protested and they
understood why their policies were bad
then maybe they'd be like you know maybe
we should stop imposing our will on
people who don't live here you know what
i mean yeah it's like um
it's a what was it what was it a family
guy episode i think where a murderer uh
uh pokes himself and he's in prison and
then like something happens and he takes
the knife looks at it and he stabs
himself and goes oh
ow
that really hurts is that what i've been
doing to people
i belong in here
it's like it's like a point about people
not realizing that they're destroying so
much because they have no idea what
they're doing they don't experience it
you know so somebody sent me an
infographic of how long it would take
for the country to completely fall apart
without truckers a very short time it
turns out uh it turns out that you would
um you'd immediately run out of oxygen
in hospitals you'd run out of medicine
in hospitals you'd run out of food you'd
run out of water you ran out of fuel
you'd stop having trash emptied and i
tweeted the truckers convoy is making me
think that our media and political
classes might benefit from a few weeks
without these distasteful cretins doing
such unimportant work as bringing food
to stores removing waste and bringing
medicine and oxygen to hospitals i
really think that our politicians and
media could do with it check this out
the truckers could come out right now
and say we want everyone to know that we
will be doing a general trucker strike
over this for the next week
no trucker will be delivering so make
sure you have adequate supplies for
whatever you need here's what will
happen
people on the right will be like you got
it boss people on the left will be like
did you watch the game last night yeah
yeah no they don't watch sports either
yeah they're probably not they're like
did you watch that bernie rally last
night or whatever it is they're watching
no they're watching like netflix
speech did you watch that netflix reboot
that was super progressive i don't know
but even they don't watch that but
they're not paying attention to the news
so they would be like what's happening
and why's it happening and it's like oh
you didn't hear they're protesting the
mandates they're like well i didn't hear
about that because it's not a racist
tweet so like why is it how does it
affect me right and they'd be victims
right i mean they're very good at
victimhood so they'd be like it's not
fair it's not well that's the point of
the truckers telling everybody like hey
heads up we're protesting for our rights
but i mean i find it really funny that
the left is opposed to workers rights
right now of course but that's the thing
they've always been the left has used
the worker as
a human shield basically for any agenda
they want to try to get across they've
totally co-opted the unions
and then they always go on public and
claim we're standing for the workers we
want it's best for them but their values
are nowhere even remotely close to those
of the average working person they have
completely different goals yeah i want
to read a couple more super chats before
we go too late uh karen ath says ian
being an incel is not about sex it's
about not having someone to love and
talk to someone to care for and start a
family with it's not about sex or we
would just get ladies of the night more
family friends vr sex vr girlfriends
won't help anything for anyone yeah also
i want to mention before for ian
responds to that when i was discussing
the fact that you do have this problem
with young men who feel they have no
bind to society doing horrific things
i'm not saying any person that you could
consider an incel is going to be a
violent or bad person and i should point
out sheamus is the one that brought up
in cells earlier
thanks for throwing me under the blaster
he's that dirty he threw me right under
that trucker convoy right there i think
he made it
a stellar point that love that that
being
celibate or
it's more about sex you know you could
easily hire somebody if you wanted to
have sex with them um but it's it's way
more than i agree with you we should
make an opening graphic that says honk
cast yeah for the uh protest
solidarity i'll make freedom tunes honky
tunes i don't know about that one that's
what it's gonna be is that why they're
calling it a racist protest calling us
honkies with their horns all right
everybody if you haven't already
smash that like button one like equals
one hunk so give this podcast a good
hunk and go to timcast.com become a
member we're gonna have a members only
podcast coming up for you around 11 or
so p.m uncensored conversations and uh
not very family friendly you can follow
the show at timcast irl follow us on
instagram for clips and you like them
and share them and all that stuff you
can follow me at timcast basically
everywhere twitter gettergab instagram
peter you want to shout anything out
uh no just uh china is a major problem
for us and i think we've had a great
conversation tonight and you have a book
i do i have a i have a book uh that is
been out for two weeks it's called red
handed it's actually been out for a week
um getting a lot of interest getting a
lot of criticism and attacks been on
number one on amazon all week um and
love love to people to check it out
that's a clever name for a book thank
you thank you i actually came up with
that myself believe it or not so yeah
did you have a social media or anything
like that uh yeah um you can go to
thedrilldown.com i've got a podcast i do
once a week it's about 25 minutes
looking at corruption
and you can also just find my
organization the government
accountability institute online we do a
lot of research on all kinds of cronyism
corruption it's a target-rich
environment
awesome sheamus coughlin thank you so
much for stopping by and watching this i
love getting an opportunity to do the
show
firstly i want to plug the after show
because i think we're going to have a
really good conversation where we go
deeper into some of this corruption and
i want to plug my youtube channel
freedom tunes go check that out we're
going to be releasing a cartoon this
week as we release every week it's going
to be about the trucker protest so can
you keep your eyes peeled for that on
thursday can we get fouchy in that
trucker protest so i can get some
royalties oh my gosh it's true so tim
tim tim voices this little character i
invented named dr fauci yes and i need
those royalty checks and the royalty
checks from freedom teams basically fund
all of the collaborations you should at
the end of the cartoon it goes to the
front of the line to the front of the
convoy and it's fouchy and he's just
trying to get home you know he doesn't
realize
what he's
hey follow me at ian crossland.net check
out my social medias there peter really
awesome conversation dude this is great
it's a lot of fun catch you guys later
man yeah i was happy to hear that peter
has a podcast somebody in this uh chat
was uh saying if you don't have one you
should so the drilldown.com that's
correct yep that's right awesome and
freedom tunes is t-o-o-n-s thank you liz
it is cartoons not music you guys may
follow me on twitter and mines at sarah
patchlets we will see you all over at
timcast.com
sign up become a member and we'll see
y'all there thanks for hanging out
you